je vous indique que j'ai reçu
aujourd'hui mardi 30 janvier à
14h30 une motion de censure déposé par
Madame Mathilde pan monsieur Boris
Vallot Madame C Chatelin monsieur André
chassigne et 146 membres de l'Assemblée
en application de l'article 49 s'il vous
plaît mes chers collègues en application
de l'article 49 alé 2 de la
Constitution en application de l'article
153 alinéa 4 de notre règlement il est
pris acte de ce dépôt la motion de
censure va être notifié au gouvernement
et affiché et la date et l'heure de la
discussion et du vote de cette motion
seront fixé par la Conférence des
président que je
réunirai l'ordre du jour appelle la
déclaration du gouvernement suivie d'un
débat au titre de l' de l'article 50-1
de la Constitution la parole est à
Monsieur le Premier Ministre
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés
le propre de toute société humaine c'est
de regarder en face l'avenir qui se
dessine devant elle interroger son
modèle puiser en soi les ressources
suffisantes pour avancer corriger ce qui
doit l'être construire les bonnes
solution une société ne se perd jamais
quand elle cherche à avancer une société
ne se perd jamais quand elle doute elle
perd quand le doute l'emporte sur tout
le reste quand le doute glace quand il
fige qu il conduit à douter non pas de
l'avenir qui se dessine mais à douter de
soi-même de ses forces de ses
capacités je suis
né je suis né en
1989 l'année du bicentenaire de la
Révolution une année 89 où l'on a cru
que la démocratie libérale et le progrès
universel triompherit par eux-mêm ma
génération a vu l'inverse se produire
parce que notre génération partout dans
le monde voit son monde chambouler plus
fortement encore que tout autre avant
elle elle est en proie au doutes doute
sur l'avenir de sa planète doute sur son
identité doute ici en France sur qui
nous sommes comme peuple et comme nation
doute sur notre modèle social sur nos
services publics sur notre
démocratie
notre responsabilité celle de chacune et
chacun d'entre nous c'est de puiser en
nous la force d'identifier tous les
ressorts pour les surpasser si nous
sommes là ici réunis si nousous
engageons pardelà nos divergences et nos
désaccords c'est que nous avons un point
commun partagé par des dizaines de
millions de nos concitoyens nous voyons
davantage de raisons d'espérer que de
douter c'est parce que nous sommes prêts
à affronter pour avancer affronter pour
avancer MAM et Messieurs les
Députés mesdames et messieurs les
députés en m'exprimant face à vous c'est
en réalité à chaque citoyen de notre
pays que je m'adresse et à travers vous
c'est à chacun de nos concitoyens que je
veux le dire nous ne sommes pas
n'importe quel pays la France n'a jamais
été n'est pas ne sera jamais une nation
qui subit ni hier ni aujourd'hui ni
demain
dans les pires moments de doute de
désarroi de désunion elle a montré sa
solidité son supplément d'âme qui fait
d'elle une nation à nul autre pareil en
cette année 2024 nous commémorerons les
80 ans du débarquement moment de
libération d'une France de soutien à des
Français qui pour la plupart n'avaient
jamais cessé de croire en elle en cette
année 2024 nous rouvrirons les portes de
NotreDame de Paris alors que l'IM
Flames rest vive dans l'esprit des
Français en cette année 2024 nous
accueillerons le monde un monde
bouleversé un monde divisé oui nous
accueillerons le monde à l'occasion des
Jeux Olympiques et
paralympique la France rime avec
puissance la France c'est un repère
c'est un idéal c'est un patrimoine
témoin d'une histoire millénaire c'est
un héritage moral celui de la patrie où
sont nés les droits de l'homme celui
d'un modèle social protecteur envié dans
le monde
entier la
France la France c'est le pays de la
création que nous soutenons et qui nous
fait rayonner c'est la patrie de la
recherche à laquelle nous donnons des
moyens sans précédent c'est la nation de
l'innovation qui construit le monde de
demain de
2030 la France ce sont nos jeunes qui
osent et qui se lancent la France ce
sont nos familles et toutes ces mères
célibataires qui se battent qui ne
lâchent rien
jamais ce sont nos soignants nos
professeurs nos forces de l'ordre tous
nos agents publics nos militaires qui
s'engagent pour quelque chose qui les
dépasse ce sont nos artisans qui font
rayonner nos savoir-faire nos
agriculteurs nos pêcheurs qui
travaillent matin midi et soir pour nous
nourrir ce sont ce sont nos élus locaux
et je suis l'un des leurs depuis 10 ans
qui s'engagent et se donent corps et
âmes pour leur territoire ce sont nos
association nos bénévoles la France
c'estes 68 millions de Français de
l'Hexagone des Outremers et de
l'étranger qui n'ont pas fini de nous
surprendre dans un monde où tout
s'accélère où tout se transforme je
refuse avec eux que notre identité
puisse se diluer ou se dissoudre la
France a son rang à tenir sa voix à
faire entendre ularité à imposer nous
avions nous avons une fierté française à
maintenir une fierté européenne à
consolider affronter pour avancer les
difficultés économiques les
bouleversements climatiques
démographiques géopolitiqu ne nous
figeront jamais ne nous conduirons
jamais à nous perdre il ne signifie pas
la fin de tout mais le passage d'un
monde à l'autre un passage difficile un
passage douloureux inquiétant à bien des
égards mais un passage que nous réuss
j'en suis intimement convaincu à ceux
qui veulent y voir notre disparition j'y
vois notre renaissance parce que nous
avons une identité et des valeurs à ceux
qui veulent y voir un triangle des
Bermudes j'y vois notre caporne parce
que nous savons où nous voulons aller et
que nous y
arriverons à ceux qui veulent y voir une
perte de boussole j'y vois une
détermination parce que j'ai confiance
confiance parce que je connais le chemin
que nous avons parcouru depuis 2017 les
tabous que nous avons levés les
obstacles que nous avons
franchi j'ai confiance s'il vous plaît
j'ai confiance parce que je connais les
Français leur énergie leur volonté leur
créativité j'ai confiance parce que face
aux épreuves aux inquiétudes aux crises
notre pays s'est toujours
relevé l'épidémie de covid a mis à jour
bon nombre de fractures dans notre
société elle a poussé notre modèle
social dans ces retranchements mais
notre pays a tenu et nous avons protégé
nos concitoyens mieux que beaucoup
d'autres l'ont
fait le dérèglement climatique nous
frappe plus dur plus fort plus souvent
l'exceptionnel devient la norme les
catastrophes se multiplient mais notre
pays agit avec force et jamais dans son
histoire les émissions de gaz à effet de
Serne nont baissé aussi rapidement que
l'an
dernier
la guerre en Ukraine a ébranlé l'Europe
elle a détruit le rêve d'une paix
éternelle sur notre continent elle nous
a rappelé durement que la démocratie
était fragile et la liberté un idéal
toujours à défendre mais notre pays
notre Europe ont montré le visage de la
détermination face à à l'agresseur et sa
solidarité pour le peuple
ukrainien l'attaque terroriste
monstrueuse en Israël et la guerre au
proche- Orient on on ravivait des plai
des mots jusque dans notre société mais
notre pays a su se dresser répondre par
le refus de la haine et par l'unité la
crise énergétique l'inflation la menace
terroriste les crises se superposent
s'enchevêtre et s'additionne elle
n'offre aucune solution miraculeuse mais
méthodiquement avec les Français nous y
répondrons bien sûr face à ces crises
pour beaucoup de Français l'avenir est
davantage une crainte qu'une promesse et
encore trop de Français ont le sentiment
de perdre le contrôle de leur propre vie
avec le président de la République avec
mon gouvernement je ne m'y résous pas je
ne m'y résoudrai
jamais pour tous c français nous allons
continuer à affronter pour avancer pas
par des belles paroles de grandes tirad
ou de beau discours mais par des actes
des actes rapides des actes concrets de
nouveau changements dans le
sur le
terrain madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés sous l'égide du
président de la République l'identité
même de cette majorité de ce
gouvernement c'est de reconquérir notre
souveraineté française et
européenne notre promesse aux Français
est claire oui nous voulons reprendre
notre destin en main en ouvrant une
nouvelle page de cette conquête nous
pouvons nous abuyer sur un bilan concret
tangible et solide en 2017 ma génération
n'avait connu que la
désindustrialisation qui semblait
inéluctable le chômage de masse qui
s'encrait l'Europe qui se désunissait la
transition écologique qui rimait avec
nécessité plus qu'avec réalité au fond
en 2017 la souveraineté de la France et
de l'Europe était pour beaucoup un
impensé pour certains même il s'agissait
d'un gros mot nous avons assumé de
parler de souveraineté et plus encore
nous avons assumé d'en faire la matrice
de notre action et nous avons agi nous
avons engagé une action résolue pour la
souveraineté économique avec pour la
première fois le retour de l'industrie
sur notre sol n'en déplaise au
Cassandre nen déplaise au Cassandre il y
a désormais plus d'usines qui ouvre que
d'usine qui ferme en France plus
d'emplois industriels qui sont créés que
d'emplois industriels qui sont détruits
en France
ça n'était pas arrivé depuis 30
ans notre taux de chômage est descendu à
un niveau jamais atteint depuis 25 ans
et pour la 5e année consécutive notre
pays le plus attractif d'Europe pour les
investissements
étrangers nous avons engagé une action
résolue pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique et conquérir
notre indépendance énergétique avec une
planification écologique inédite dans le
monde et une stratégie énergétique pour
une énergie plus souveraine et plus
durable nous avons engagé une action
résolue pour la souveraineté de nos
frontières avec une loi immigration et
un Pact asile immigration au niveau
européen enfin réellement protecteur de
notre
pays nous avons engagé une action
résolue elle prendra du temps pour que
chaque française chaque Français puisse
garder le contrôle de sa propre vie
qu'il ne soit jamais entravé jamais
assigné à résidence jamais résigné et
évidemment nous avons engagé une action
pour la souveraineté agricole de notre
pays mesdames et messieurs les députés
je le dis ici dès le début de cette
intervention notre agriculture est une
force pas simplement parce qu'elle nous
alimente au sens propre du terme mais
parce qu'elle constitue un des
fondements de notre identité de nos
traditions parce que nos agriculteurs
incarnent des valeurs fondamentales et
qui lorsqu'ils sont lorsqu'elles sont
bridées fragilisent l'ensemble de la
société je pense à la valeur travail à
l'effort et à la liberté
d'entreprendre
notre agriculture est une force et notre
fierté aussi alors je le dis ici
solennellement il y a et il doit y avoir
une exception agricole française je suis
lucide je suis lucide face à
l'empilement des normes face aux
décisions qui tombent d'en haut et qui
parfois tombent d'on ne sait où
l'agriculture doute elle aussi et elle
attend des réponses et des solutions
nous au rendez-vous sans aucune
ambigué madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés alle un peu de
silence s'il vous plaît devant vous je
prends la parole conscient de l'ampleur
de la tâche à accomplir je veux
m'adresser à tous les Français à ceux
qui doutent et à ceux qui espèrent à
ceux qui écoutent et à ceux qui n'y croi
plus je veux m'adresser à tous ces
Français souvent de la classe moyenne
toujours au rendez-vous de leur
responsabilité qui ne se plaignent pas
alors qu'ils ont souvent le sentiment de
subir
à ces Français qui ont le sentiment
d'avoir tous les devoirs quand d'autres
ont tous les droits à ces Français qui
ont parfois le sentiment que leur propre
pays s'éloigent qu'ils n'y ont plus
vraiment leur place alors qu'ils en sont
le cœur battant à ces Français de
l'Entre Deux trop riches pour bénéficier
des aides mais pas assez pour ne pas
compter qui ont le sentiment que les
décisions se prennent sans eux et qu'ell
bénéficient toujours au
même FO l'impression de vivre dans une
France archipelle dont les ponts
seraient sur le point de rompre mais ces
Français qui espèrent au fond deeux
qu'on parviendra à les réunir à ces
Français qui ne demandent pas la lune
mais simplement à pouvoir vivre de leur
travail éduquer leurs enfants se soigner
et vivre en
sécurité je les entends je les comprends
et comme la majorité Yvre depuis 2017 je
veux contribuer à leur répondre je le
veux avec d'autant plus determination
nation que je sais le risque pour eux de
les laisser céder à des sirènes qui ne
conduiraient qu'au chaos à la division
et à l'effondrement car je suis
lucide que pendant que nous agissons
certains guettes entretiennent les
colères et espèrent en récolter les
fruits mesdames et messieurs les députés
le défi est immense et j'ai bien
conscience que nous ne pourrons pas le
relever seul avec mes ministres que je
remercie pour leur engagement sans
faille j'ai bien conscience aussi du
message très clair exprimé par les
Français en 2022
nous avons une majorité que je salue à
qui je veux dire ma confiance et ma
fidélité mais cette majorité est
relative et les Français attend que nous
cessionions les querelles de principe
pour échanger et pour agir
ensemble depuis 2 depuis 2022 depuis 18
mois sur bien des textes nous y sommes
parvenus et aujourd'hui je le dis à la
majorité comme aux oppositions nous
avons la France en partage nous avons je
le crois un devoir commun de transcender
les cvag les désaccords et lesis
pour au service des
Français évidemment nous ne serons pas
d'accord sur tout évidemment nous nous
opposerons dans cet hémicycle et
ailleurs mais je vous le dis je ne
renoncerai jamais à dialoguer ma porte
sera toujours ouverte parce qu'à travers
vous mesdames et messieurs les députés
des oppositions ce sont les voies de
millions de Français qui s'expriment
même si je ne suis pas convaincu que ces
millions de Français attendent qu'on
cherche à couvrir son interlocuteur par
des cris pendant qu'il intervient dans
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est aussi cela la méthode
que je veux pour mon gouvernement
respecter les Français respecter les
oppositions respecter notre Parlement je
m'y engage j'en serai le garant ma
méthode a toujours été la même chaque
Français porte une vérité sur notre pays
nous devons l'écouter et y répondre
force politique organisations syndicales
élus locaux français depuis ma
nomination j'ai entamé des échanges
toujours avec franchise et lucidité
alors avec vous je veux chercher à faire
raisonner les mots de nos concitoyens
répondre à leurs inquiétudes et porter
leurs espoirs alors Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés ma priorité est
claire favoriser le travail pour que
ceux qui en sont éloignés s'en
rapprochent en soutenant ceux qui n'ont
que le fruit de leur travail pour vivre
et qui sont toujours au rendez-vous de
leur
responsabilité
mon CAP est clair c'est celui de la
souveraineté et de l'indépendance à
l'échelle individuelle nationale et
européenne ma méthode est claire elle
reste la même dire les choses dire la
vérité même quand ça fait mal même quand
ça nous conduit à remettre en cause nos
propres décisions dire la vérité donc et
agir agir vraiment agir maintenant
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés parler au français
c'est au fond entendre qure appels à
l'action pour le travail pour qu'il paye
mieux et toujours plus que l'inactivité
partout et pour tous pour nos services
publics pour qu'ils soit accessible et
de qualité partout et pour tous pour
l'autorité le civisme le respect des
droits et devoirs partout et pour tous
pour un environnement plus respirable
partout et pour tous et je veux
l'affirmer nous n'avons pas à renoncer
aux grandes conquêtes et à la création
de droits nouveaux mesdames et messieurs
les députés pour le travail pour nos
services publics et le rétablissement de
l'autorité dans notre société pour la
transition écologique nous partons
aujourd'hui d'un bilan solide derrière
le cap fixé par le président de la
République nous avons multiplié les
actions et les réformes et je veux
rendre ici hommage à l'action
déterminante d'Édouard Philippe Jean
Castex et ellisabeth borne don le sens
de l'État et la détermination à faire
sont des
exemples je veux rendre hommage à la
majorité toujours mobilisée pour
améliorer le quotidien des Français je
veux saluer tous les parlementaires qui
ont acc accepter de sortir des logiques
partisanes pour permettre l'adoption de
nombreux
textes aujourd'hui les résultats sont là
depuis 2017 nous avons montré que le
chômage de mche n'était pas une fatalité
nous avons engagé des réformes fortes
qui avait été trop longtemps repoussé
nous avons pris les ordonnances travail
dès le début du premier quinquena nous
avons mené une réforme de l'assurance
chômage une réforme de l'apprentissage
une réforme des retraites nous avons
lancé le contrat d'engagement jeune
baisser les impôts et les charges et
engagé une réforme
du lycée professionnel aujourd'hui le
chômage a baissé de 2 points 2 millions
d'emplois ont été créés notre industrie
revient avec 100000 emplois industriel
créé et la réouverture de 300 usines le
nombre d'apprentis a plus que triplé ils
sont déjormais plus de 850000 en France
et nous avons le cap du million en
vue depuis 2017 nous avons agi
massivement pour nos services publics
pour notre santé AC les milliards
d'euros du Ségure de la santé avec une
revalorisation historique des soignants
l'augmentation du nombre de places en
études de médecine d'infirmiers d'
soignant pour notre école nous avons
engagé des transformations majeures et
agit pour l'égalité des chances je pense
au dédoublement des classes ou encore à
l'augmentation du salaire des
enseignants la plus forte depuis 30
[Musique]
ans pour notre sécurité nous avons
investi comme jamais par le passé 10000
postes de policiers et gendarmes ont été
créés lors du premier quinena 8500 de
plus le seront lors de celui-ci et nous
avons lancé la création de 238 brigades
de gendarmerie nouvelle la sécurité ça
doit être pour tous y compris dans la
ruralité et dans les petites
villes depuis 2017 17 pour la planète
nous avons préféré au grand mot les
vrais actes nous agissons et nous
agissons plus qu'aucune majorité avant
nous avant 2017 les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre baissai d' 1 % en moyenne
en France dans le premier quinena elles
ont baissé de 2 % en moyenne en France
l'an dernier sur les 9 mois les 9
premiers mois de l'année seulement elles
ont baissé de près de 5 % c'est le
crédit de notre action sur la transition
écologique et conformément à
l'engagement du président de la
République nous avons désormais une
stratégie complète secteur par secteur
territoire par territoire la
planification écologique nous nous
donnons les moyens de réussir et nous
investissons cette année 40 milliards
d'euros pour la transition écologique
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés nous avons
beaucoup fait mais il reste encore du
chemin alors avec mon gouvernement je
suis prêt je suis déterminé nous devons
répondre aux inquiétudes de la classe
moyenne et faire en sorte que ceux qui
vont travailler puissent vivre dignement
de leur travail et gagnent toujours plus
que ceux qui ne travaillent pas nous
devons répondre au défis des emplois non
pourvu car il est incompréhensible que
le chômage reste autour de 7 % alors
qu'il y a tant d'entreprises
ch à recuter partout sur le territoire
national nous avons en France un
paradoxe nous avons un salire minimum un
SMIC nettement supérieur à celui de nos
voisins et nous en sommes fiers mais
nous avons une part de nos travailleurs
proches du SMIC beaucoup plus importante
que nos voisins c'est un problème
d'abord nous agirons résolument pour que
les branches professionnelles qui
continuent à rémunérer enous
remonte ses rémunérations c'était le cas
d'une soixantaine d'entre elles l'été
dernier grâce à la mobilisation engagée
alors nous étions descendus à une
trentaine à la fin de l'année 2023 la
revalorisation du SMIC au 1er janvier
dernier en a fait redescendre une partie
en dessous du SMIC je demande de
poursuivre et amplifier la mobilisation
pour des résultats rapides et je
n'exclus aucune mesure pour y
parvenir
ensuite nous devons faire évoluer un
système qui nous a conduit je le disais
il y a un instant depuis des décennies à
concentrer nos aides nos exonérations au
niveau du SMIC aujourd'hui pour
augmenter de 100 € le revenu d'un
employé au SMIC l'employeur doit
débourser 238 € de plus quant au
salariés il perd 39 € de prime
d'activité il voit sa CSG et ses
cotisations sociales augmenter de 26 %
et il rentre dans l'impôt sur le revenu
en bref autant le dire notre système
fruit de réformec exessive prespéterie
de bonnes intentions ces dernières
décennies a placé notre monde économique
dans une situation où il n'y a quasiment
plus aucun intérêt pour quiconque à
augmenter un salarié au Smic on ne peut
accepter une France où beaucoup sont
condamnés à rester proche du SMIC toute
leur
carrière la progression salariale doit
toujours permettre de récompenser
l'effort et le le mérite alors oui
j'assume de le dire il faut dmicardiser
la France dès le prochain projet de loi
de
finance en nous appuyant sur les
propositions de parlementaires de
partenaires sociaux et sur un certain
nombre de travaux d'experts qui sont
actuellement conduits nous commencerons
à réformer ce système dans le même temps
nous devons continuer à baisser les
charges qui pèsent sur la classe moyenne
après la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation de la redevance télé la
baisse de 5 milliards d'euros des
premières tranches de l'impôt sur le
revenu nous tiendrons l'engagement du
président de la République d'une
nouvelle baisse d'impôt de 2000 ur cette
baisse d'impôt sera financée et la
solidarité nationale devra s'exercer
pour nos classes moyennes valoriser le
travail ce n'est pas seulement pour les
salariés nous agirons aussi pour nos
fonctionnaires qui permettent à l'état
d'avancer et s'engage au service de
l'intérêt général en intégrant leurs
mérites et leurs efforts à leur
rémunération un projet de loi sera
déposé dès le second semestre de cette
année nous agirons pour nos indépendants
tous nos commerçants nos artisans nos
agriculteurs qui sont indépendants en
2026 nous aurons réformé l'assiette
sociale des indépendant cela veut dire
plus de droit notamment à la retraite
sans payer davantage de cotisation c'est
l'engagement de cette
majorité deuxè objectif pour réussir je
veux déverrouiller l'accès au travail
déverrouiller notre société je veux
permettre à tous ceux qui le peuvent de
travailler avec en tête les droits et
les devoirs de chacun le droit d'être
mieux accompagné grâce à la réforme de
France travail mais aussi le devoir de
chercher un emploi dans 18 départements
nous avons lancé une expérimentation qui
conditionne le RSA à 15 he d'activité
pour l'insertion je vous annonce que
nous généraliserons ce dispositif à tous
les départements de France d'ici le 1er
janvier
2025 de plus nous devons aller plus loin
dans la réforme de l'assurance chômage
une négociation a été lancée en faveur
de l'emploi des seniors de la prévention
de l'usure professionnell des parcours
et des reconversions et nous souhaitons
qu'elle aboutisse à un résultat
ambitieux mais la situation économique
évolue parce que nous gardons notre
objectif de plein emploi et que nous
devons inciter toujours plus à la
reprise du travail je serai extrêmement
attentif à l'évolution de la trajectoire
financière de l'assurance chômage si
cette dernière dévie je n'hésiterai pas
comme la loi le permet a demandé aux
partenaires sociaux de remettre
l'ouvrage sur le métier sur la base
d'une nouvelle lettre de cadrage
ambitions très clair Incit toujours plus
à la repris d'emploi sans aucun
tabout nous assumerons également de
combattre toutes les trappes à
inactivité d'un côté en rendant les
droits effectifs nous avons été capables
de faire le prélèvement à la source nous
serons capables de mener à bien le
chantier de la solidarité à la source
pour éviter les démarches inutiles
garantir la justice sociale pour que
chacun touche l'intégralité de ce à quoi
il a
droit combattre les trappes à inactivité
c'est permettre le droit effectif de
chacun grâce à la solidarité à la source
et je l'assume c'est aussi assumer de
réinterroger notre modèle je pense
notamment à la location de solidarité
spécifique qui prolongeindemnisation du
chômage et qui permet sans travailler de
valider des trimestres de retraite nous
avons une conviction et une cohérence
forte nous considérons que la retraite
doit être le fruit du travail
et donc nous proposerons la bascule de
l'allocation de solidarité spécifique
RSA et la suppression de cette
allocation chercher un modèle social
plus efficace et moins coûteux ce n'est
pas un gros mot c'est un
impératif déverrouiller le travail c'est
aussi l'adapter aux nouvelles
aspirations de nos concitoyens c'est un
fait le rapport au travail a changé je
mesure dans ma génération comme dans les
autres les changements de mentalité les
nouvelles attentes sur les horaires sur
sur l'équilibre entre vie
professionnelle et vie familiale ces
aspirations ne doivent pas être niées
elles ne doivent pas être caricaturer
non plus au risque de décevoir certains
ici personne ne demande un droit à la
paresse dans notre
pays non ces aspirations elles doivent
être regardées pour ce qu'ell sont notre
rapport au travail c'est notre rapport
au temps à l'équilibre personnel on peut
pas appliquer les mêmes calques
génération après génération les attentes
changent les technologies évoluent et
font apparaître de nouvelles fractures
je pense notamment à celles entre ceux
qui peuvent télétravailler et ceux qui
ne peuvent pas télétravailler alors les
conditions de travail doivent aussi
évoluer et l'État doit donner
l'exemple comme ministre des comptes
publics j'avais décidé
d'expériment d'expérimenter dans mon
administration non pas la semaine de 4
jours mais la semaine en 4 jours sans
réduction du temps de travail à certains
endroits il y a eu peu de candidats je
l'avoue à d'autres ils sont nombreux à
avoir choisi de pouvoir arriver plus tôt
le matin partir plus tard le soir pour
travailler un jour de moins comme
premier ministre je demande à l'ensemble
de mes ministres d'expérimenter cette
solution dans leurs administrations
centrales et déconcentré
oui l'État doit donner l'exemple
s'agissant de l'organisation du travail
notamment pour toutes ces personnes qui
travaillent dur et qui se sentent
invisibles je pense notamment aux
personnes du ménage parfois forcé à
faire des heures de transport en commun
au milieu de la nuit tout ça pour éviter
qu'elle ne travaille en même temps que
les salariés et qu'elle croise les
agents qui sont dans les bureaux là
aussi je veux que l'État montre
l'exemple et que désormais dans l'état
les personnels d'entretien de
l'administration qui le souhait puissent
travailler aux mêmes horaires que tout
le monde c'est-à-dire aux horaires de
bureau oui nous devons mieux prendre en
compte notre rapport au temps et N nous
considerons à avancer dans le chantier
du compte épintant universel véritable
sac à dos social qui doit permettre à
ceux qui le souhaitent de travailler un
peu de silence s'il vous plaît mes chers
collègues juste un peu de silence il y a
un Brou continue je vous remercie de
bien vouloir Mons don merci Monsieur le
Premier Ministre je pense madame la
Présidente qu'ils ont compris que je ne
m'arrêterai pas malgré leur hurlement et
donc je peux continuer sans aucune
difficulté
mieux prendre en compte notre rapport au
temps et nous continuerons à avancer
dans le chantier du compte épin de temps
universel je l'ai dit il y a un instant
véritable sac à dos social qui doit
permettre à ceux qui le souhaitent de
travailler beaucoup plus à certains
moments de leur vie où ils le peuvent
notamment quand ils sont jeunes et n'ont
pas encore de responsabilité familiale
pour pouvoir ensuite à d'autres moments
de leur vie travailler moins pour
développer un projet pour s'occuper de
sa famille ou d'un proche qui en a
besoin
déverrouiller notre économie c'est aussi
conquérir de nouvelles libertés refuser
le principe de rente être capable de
continuer à transformer et libérer un
projet de loi en ce sens sera examiné au
printemps il permettra notamment de
déverrouiller certaines profession comme
les syndicques ou encore les ventes en
ligne de médicaments par les pharmacies
mesdames et messieurs les députés
beaucoup d'entre vous me l'ont dit si
est un secteur qu'il faut déverrouiller
c'est bien le logement le problème du
logement clair il tient à la fois à
l'offre et à la demande or pourvoir se
loger acquérir son logement c'est pour
tant de Français le projet d'une vie
l'assurance d'une retraite sereine en
lien avec les élus locaux nous
répondrons à cette crise du logement en
créant un choc d'offre avec CQ solutions
immédiates
proposées d'abord nous allons simplifier
massivement les normes revoir les DPE
simplifier l'accès à ma prime Renov
faciliter la densification lever les
contraintes sur le zonage accélérer les
procédures ensuite nous désignerons dans
2 semaines 20 territoires engagés pour
le logement où nous accélérerons toutes
les procédures comme nous avons su le
faire pour les Jeux Olympiques et
Paralympiques avec pour objectif d'y
créer 30000 nouveaux logements d'ici 3
ans nous n'hésiterons pas à procéder à
des réquisitions pour des bâtiments
vides notamment des bâtiments de bureau
nous l'avons déjà fait et nous
continuerons à le faire nous
continuerons à soutenir le monde
logemental nous avons agi pour lui en
maintenant le TX du livra avec 1,2
milliard d'euros pour le rénovation
énergétique avec des plan de rachat
massif nous voulons également répondre
aux causes structurelles de la crise du
logement social le coût élevé du foncier
avec un nouveau prêt de très long terme
2 milliards d'euros distribués par la
banque des territoires et nous allons
aussi contribuer à faire évoluer le
monde du logement social le faire
évoluer pour inciter les élus à
développer de nouveaux programmes aussi
je vous annonce que nous allons donné au
maire la main pour la première
attribution dans les nouveaux logements
sociaux construits sur leur communes
c'était une mesure attendue par les élus
locaux nous allons aussi engager un
chantier une réflexion pour faire
évoluer le logement social pour qu'il
réponde davantage aux classes moyennes
vous le savez d'ici 2025 toutes les
communes soumises à la loi SRU doivent
posséder au moins un/art de logements
sociaux sur leur territoire nous
proposerons et nous mettrons en débat
d'ajouter pour une part les logements
intermédiaires accessibles à la classe
moyenne dans ce calcul des 25
%. mesdames et messieurs les députés
dmicardiser pour promouvoir le travail
déverrouiller pour libérer la croissance
je veux aussi débureaucratiser la France
je veux alléger le fardeau des règles et
des normes qui pèsent sur ceux qui
créent TPE et nos PME sur tous ces
Français qui travaillent sans compter et
qui créent de l'activité et de l'emploi
il a été évalué que chaque année ce sont
60 milliards d'euros que nous perdons à
cause des démarches et des complexités
de notre quotidien aussi nous engagerons
après l'été une nouvelle étape de la
réforme du droit du travail avec un
objectif clair libérer nos PPE et nos
PME simplifier considérablement leur
quotidien et leur permettre de négocier
certaines règles directement entreprise
par entreprise mais cet élan de
simplification ne doit pas se se limiter
au travail partout dans notre pays les
Français me racontent combien les normes
les oppressent les brides les empêche de
faire et d'avancer je pense à nos
agriculteurs évidemment je pense à tous
les petits patrons je pense à nos élus
locaux qui croulent sous les règles et
les procédurees
administratives à date à date le nombre
de mots pour dire des normes sur l'égif
France s'élève à 44,1 million de mots
c'est pratiquement de fois plus qu'il y
a 20 ans à tous les échelons il faut
débureaucratiser la
France nous évaluerons les normes qui
peuvent être supprimées ou simplifiées
avec les Français avec les
professionnels avec les élus nous
regarderons les démarches qui peuvent
être améliorées tous les sujets sont sur
la table mon seul objectif c'est de
libérer les Français dans leurs
initiatives c'est de les laisser vivre
et respirer supprimer des normes c'est
possible vendredi dernier j'ai annoncé
la suppression de 10 premières normes
nationales pour nos agriculteurs et
beaucoup d'autres suivront au niveau
local en Haute Garonne en quelques
réunions sur une semaine la semaine
dernière le préfet et les agriculteurs
se sont accordés sur l'abrogation de
quatre arrêtés préfectorau cette logique
est étendue dès cette semaine à
l'ensemble des départements
français simplifier les démarches c'est
possible et je vous annonce que dès
cette année chacun pourra enfin porter
plainte en ligne partout sur le
territoire simplifier pour éviter
simplifier pour éviter la gabgie c'est
possible et je vous annonce une nouvelle
une nouvelle règle générale simple tous
les organes tous les organismes tous les
comités ou autres qui ne se sont pas
réunis ces 12 derniers mois seront
supprimés par règle
générale
enfin enfin despend entier de notre
économie demande des simplification
encore drastique notamment pour
accélérer le retour de notre
industrie pourquoi parce que trop de
délais c'est moins de projet et donc
moins d'emploi et moins de croissance
quand un investisseur veut implanter un
projet en Europe quelque chose lui saute
aux yeux en France il faut 17 mois en
moyenne pour implanter un projet
industriel en Allemagne c'est deux fois
moins ça ne peut pas
continuer avec le projet de loi
industrie verte nous avons marqué une
première étape je vous annonce que nous
déposerons un deuxième projet de loi
industrie verte il proposera notamment
de demander à la CNDP de concentrer ses
travaux uniquement sur les projets
d'envergure nationale ce sera 6 mois de
gagnner dans les procédures pour les
autres
projets
la bureaucratie qui recule c'est la
liberté qui avance je veux libérer les
Français des contraintes qui les
freinent et sont autant de boulets pour
notre économie madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
déverrouillé désmicardisé
débureaucratisé oui mais dans un seul
objectif réarmer notre pays je veux le
dire d'emblé le préalable du réarmement
de la France c'est la responsabilité
budgétaire nous devons faire preuve
d'une responsabilité exemplaire dans nos
finances publ il en va de notre
souveraineté il en va de la survie de
notre modèle social il en va de la
protection des plus
fragiles de la protection des classes
moyennes qui seraient les premières
victimes des coupes massives et des
hausses drastiques auxquels nous serions
contraints si nous ne tenons pas notre
trajectoire de réduction des déficits et
de notre dette et je le dis pour nous le
meilleur moyen de réduire nos déficits
ça restera le travail et la croissance
pour certains la croissance est un gros
mot
et pour cela on a que le mot taxer à la
bouche tout y est passé dans les
propositions parlementaires ces deux
dernières années j'étais au première
loge en tant que ministre du Budget vous
avez voulu taxer les heures
supplémentaires des ouvriers le
patrimoine des retraités et même les
successions des petits agriculteurs à
cela je le réaffirme quand on taxe tout
très vite il n'y a plus rien à taxer et
on ne taxe plus rien du
tout
je vous confirme que nous poursuivrons
le même cap repasser sous les 3 % de
déficit public d'ici 2027 grâce à plus
de croissance plus d'activité à la
maîtrise de nos dépenses pas grâce à
trop d'impôts grâce à des économies de
structure aussi nous mettrons toutes nos
forces dans la bataille nous allons
poursuivre et renforcer les revues de
dépenses auxquel tous les ministères et
tous les secteurs de l'actions publiques
seront associées les premières
propositions d'économie pour le prochain
PLF issu de ce travail ser ont annoncé
dès le mois de mars et je souhaite
qu'elle donne lieu très vite à des
échanges avec la représentation
nationale madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés ce réarmement
que nous construisons avec le président
de la République il a un objectif
prioritaire assumer notre souverainété
alors oui nous continuerons à renforcer
notre souveraineté nationale et
européenne où nos frontières doivent
être respectées la lutte contre
l'immigration illégale doit continuer à
s'intensifier il faut assumer
d'accueillir moins pour accueillir mieux
nous continuerons à déployer la border
force lancée dans les alpes maritimes
qui a déjà permis plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'interpellations à la
frontière italienne je tiendrai
l'engagement de ma prédécesseur de
réformer l'aide médicale d'État nous le
ferons avant l'été par voie
réglementaire avec une base qui est
connue le rapport evvin
stéphanini défendre notre souveraineté
nationale c'est aussi donner les moyens
nécessaires à nos armées pour protéger
nos territoires et valeurs nos
militaires se battent au péril de leur
vie pour défendre notre pays et notre
République et dans le cadre de la loi de
programmation militaire nous tiendrons
nos engagements vis-à-vis d'eux en deux
quinquenas nous aurons doublé le budget
du ministère de la
défense avec vous tous avec vous toutes
je veux rendre hommage aux femmes et aux
hommes de nos armées rendre hommage à
ceux qui sont tombés pour nous défendre
leur sacrifice nous oblige notre
reconnaissance est infinie
notre souveraineté c'est aussi notre
capacité à répondre aux besoins de nos
concitoyens et donc sur ces fondements
nous allons réarmer nos services publics
ils ont toujours été une fierté ils
doivent le rester et pour certains
d'entre eux le redevenir nous allons
continuer à réarmer notre système de
santé et avec vous je veux rendre
hommage à tous les soignants de France
chacun à leur poste chacun dans leur
spécialités ils sont les visages de
l'engagement de
l'accompagnement de l'attention et de
l'humanité
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui quel est le
problème malgré le travail de nos
soignants le temps médical manque un peu
de silence nos compatriotes ne trouvent
pas suffisamment de médecins et les
délais aux urgences se rallongent cela
se traduit par la désertification de
notre pays et par la saturation de nos
de nos hôpitaux et en particulier des
urgences l'objectif est clair plus de
temps médical
premier pilier agir pour qu'il y ait
plus de médecins devant les Français les
effets de la suppression du numérus
closus ne se feront pas sentir
immédiatement alors nous devons mettre
en œuvre des solutions fortes tout de
suite c'est pourquoi comme l'a annoncé
le président de la République nous
procéderons à la régularisation des
médecins étrangers sur notre
territoire c'est pourquoi aussi je vous
l'annonce jeom chargé d'aller chercher à
l'étranger des médecins qui voudrai
venir exercer en France et nous devons
trouver les moyens de faire revenir nos
jeunes Français qui sont parti étudier à
[Applaudissements]
l'étranger nous devons aussi nous devons
aussi et c'est ce qu'a proposé le député
Neer mieux reconnaître l'expertise et la
volonté de soignants qui ont fait
beaucoup d'études et qui ont une vraie
expérience une infirmière anesthésiste
qui a un bac + 5 plusieurs années de
carrière et d'expérience elle doit
pouvoir si elle le souhaite rentrer
directement au moins en 3è année de
médecine pour devenir médecin si elle le
souhaite deuxème pilier agir pour qu'il
n'y ait aucun territoire oublié nous
avons depuis 2017 déployé le service
d'accès aux soins le sas il permet un
progrès notable dans l'accès aux soins
non programmés je l'ai vu encore
récemment à Dijon dès cet été chaque
département devra être doté d'un service
d'accès au soins avec des professionnels
organisés pour assurer la permanence des
soins dans les départements où il n'y
aurait toujours pas de service d'accès
aux soins et de réponse satisfaisante je
suis prêt à aller plus loin en
restaurant des obligations de garde pour
les médecins libéraux en soirée ou le
weekend dans leur cabinet à l'hôpital ou
en maison de
santé
troème pilier libérer les médecins pour
qu'ils se concentrent sur le soin nous
poursuivrons les chantiers que nous
avons engagé notamment pour
l'attractivité de tous les métiers du
soin nous allons accélérer le passage de
6000 à 10000 assistants médicaux qui
permettront au médecins de pouvoir se
concentrer consacrer davantage aux
patients et moins en formalités
administrativ concrètement cela
représente 2 millions et demi de
consultations supplémentaires libérées
tous les ans pour les
patients ensuite nous allons poursuivre
notre action en faveur de l'hôpital les
moyens du Ségure de la santé ne sont pas
encore arrivés partout ces lourdeurs ces
lenteurs sont insupportable cela
changera rapidement enfin il y a encore
aujourd'hui trop de rendez-vous médicaux
qui ne sont pas honorés pour les
médecins il est insupportable d'avoir
chaque jour des patients qui ont un
rendez-vous et qui ne se présentent pas
pour les Français il est insupportable
de savoir que des millions d'heures sont
perdus alors qu'ils attendent parfois
des mois pour un rendez-vous je souhaite
un principe simple qui se traduisent par
des mesures claires dès cette année
quand on a rendez-vous chez le médecin
et qu'on ne vient pas sans prévenir on
paye protéger nos concitoyens c'est
aussi les accompagner à tous les âges de
la vie et à toutes les étapes de la vie
nous continuerons à agir pour l'enfance
notamment l'enfance en danger nous
continuerons à bâtir une société où
chacun peut vieillir dignement comme il
l'entend en facilitant le maintien à
domicile de ceux qui le souhaitent et en
améliorant le quotidien en épade le défi
humain et financier est immense et nous
avancerons ensemble mesdames et
messieurs les députés parler de santé
c'est trop souvent oublier la santé
mentale le mal-être les dépressions les
pensées suicidaires ont beaucoup
progressé chez nos jeunes je veux faire
de la santé mentale de notre jeunesse
une grande cause de notre action
gouvernementale avec là aussi des
mesures claires et immédiates
d'abord réformer le dispositif mon
soutien PSI il faut être lucide ce
dispositif partait d'une bonne intention
mais il n'a pas donné les résultats
escomtés il faut avoir le courage de le
reconnaître même si c'est nous qui
l'avons mis en
place je vous annonce donc que nous
allons le rénover de fond en comble nous
allons augmenter le tarif de la
consultation remboursée pour limiter au
maximum le reste à charge pour les
jeunes patients et leurs familles et
pour lever tous les verrous nous
permettrons aussi aux jeunes d'avoir
accès directement au au psychologue
prise en charge sans nécessairement
passer par un
médecin de plus nous allons mailler
notre territoire de maison départemental
des adolescents il y en a 50 aujourd'hui
je souhaite qu'il y en ait une par
département dans notre
pays pour la santé et notamment la santé
psychologique les infirmières scolaires
sont des relais essentiel auprès des
élèves elles accomplissent un travail
remarquable elles accompagnent les
jeunes avec ibilité écoute et soin nous
devons recruter davantage d'infirmières
scolaires et mieux reconnaître leur
engagement aussi je vous annonce et
c'est grâce à un amendement porté par
cette majorité un budget supplémentaire
dans le dernier PLF que j'ai décidé de
verser aux infirmières scolaires en mai
prochain une prime exceptionnelle de 800
€ et de revaloriser leur salairire de
200 € net par mois à compter de cette
date
je demande également au gouvernement de
travailler à des revalorisations pour
les autres personnels sociaux et
sanitaires en milieu scolaire madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés renforcer nos pouvoirs publics
c'est aussi agir pour notre école je
veux ici rendre hommage à nos
professeurs ils s'investissent tous les
jours au service de notre école de nos
élèves et donc de notre
pays
j'ai souvent dit ma fierté d'être leur
ministre et aujourd'hui comme premier
ministre je n'oublie rien de ce que nous
leur devons et je serai toujours à leur
côté je l'ai dit sur le Peron de l'hôtel
de
[Applaudissements]
matigon je l'ai dit sur le pon l'ôel de
matigon dès mes premières minutes comme
premier ministre l'école est la mer des
batailles sur l'école là aussi il faut
partir de la réalité des faits et pas
uniquement des classements
internationaux il suffit d'écouter ce
que nous disent nos français et
notamment les parents et les
grands-parents que nous disent--il que
ces dernières décennies le niveau a
baissé que si le nombre d'heures
d'absence remplacé à triplé ces derniers
mois le compte n est toujours pas que
nous disent les professeurs qu'il croi
en leur métier mais qu'il est de plus en
plus difficile à exercer qus ont parfois
peur d'enseigner dépend entiers de notre
histoire et de notre
littérature que nous disent les jeunes
qui envisageent de devenir enseignant
que la formation initiale telle qu'elle
est organisée ne correspond pas à leurs
attentes et freine leur
vocation nous allons continuer à leur
répondre pour élever le niveau des
élèves j'avais lancé le choc des savoirs
il doit maintenant se déployer le choc
des savoirs c'est assumer que tout le
monde ne progresse pas au même rythme
que tout le monde n'a pas les mêmes
facilité ou les mêmes difficultés la
décision du redoublement sera désormais
à la main de l'équipe pédagogique et les
groupes de niveau commenceront à se
mettre en place dès cette année dans nos
collèges parce qu'une école du passage
automatique où l'on glisse de classe en
classe sans vérifier si on a le niveau
pour passer dans la classe supérieure
c'est une école où tout le monde stagne
où le niveau baisse nous assumons de
porter une école des savoirs de exence
de l'excellence où chacun apprend à son
rythme améliorer les savoirs c'est
évidemment aussi agir sur la question
des remplacements nous évaluerons le
pacte enseignant et si de nouvelles
mesures s'imposent nous les prendrons
veiller au niveau des élèves c'est
réagir face au nouveaux défis qui les
menacent les écrans sont une catastrophe
éducative et sanitaire en puissance nous
avons d'ors et déjà interdit le portable
au collège et comme l'a annoncé le
président de la République nous
travaillerons à mieux réguler l'usage
des écrans dans et en dehors de l'école
pour nos
[Musique]
enfants j'ajoute qu'une école des
savoirs c'est aussi une école qui permet
de se projeter dans l'avenir désormais
tous les élèves de secondes devront
faire un stage de 2 semaines nous
continuerons à rapprocher l'école de
l'entreprise des métiers des
administrations des
associations une école qui fonctionne
c'est une école où nos professeurs sont
mieux formés nous réformerons la
formation des ignants pour construire
les écoles normales du 21e siècle cette
réforme sera présentée d'ici au mois de
mars une école qui marche c'est aussi
une école où les élèves sont heureux
trop longtemps le bien-être des élèves
est resté un impensé le résultat nous le
connaissons ce sont notamment les drames
du harcèlement notre stratégie contre le
harcèlement qui a permis de briser des
tabous majeurs et très concrètes
désormais c'est l'élève harceleur qui
doit quitter l'école plus l'élève
victime qui subissait la double peine je
suis fier que nous ayons décidé de ce
changement le bien-être à l'école c'est
aussi donner toute leur place aux élèves
en situation de handicap bâtir une
société inclusive est au cœur des
priorités de mon gouvernement cela vaut
dans tous les domaines j'y suis très
attentif nous accompagnerons nos
concitoyens en situation de handicap en
toute circonstan nous leur simplifierons
la vie nous prendrons intégralement en
charge le remboursement des fauteuils
roulants de ceux qui en ont besoin comme
nous y sommes engag
nous agirons partout et particulièrement
à l'école depuis des années l'État et
les collectivité se renvoie la balle sur
la prise en charge des aesh sur la pose
du Midi résultat dans beaucoup
d'endroits personne ne le finance et la
conséquence c'est une double défaite des
élèves qui ne sont pas suffisamment bien
accompagnés au moment du repas et des
AES qui ne peuvent pas faire un temps
complet pour améliorer leur rémunération
il faut sortir de cette situation où
chacun se renvoie la balle je prends
cision claire l'état prendra ses
responsabilités et financera désormais
l'accompagnement des enfants en
situation de handicap sur le temps du
déjeuner en lieu et place des
collectivités
locales c'est un enjeu de solidarité de
dignité et de reconnaissance réarmer
l'école c'est réaffirmer nos valeurs car
je crois que la transmission du savoir
est impossible sans respect de
l'autorité sans respect de nos valeurs
républicaines au premier rang desquels
la laïcité on ne négocie pas avec la
République on l'accepte on la respecte
en entier sans ma sans la moindre
exception c'est pourquoi nous déploirons
l'expérimentation de l'uniforme à
l'école symbole d'égalité républicaine
et comme l'annoncé le président de la
République si cette expérimentation est
conclliante nous généraliserons
l'uniforme en France à la rentrée 2 26
je veux le dire également je ne peux pas
me résoudre à ce que certains
professeurs craignent d'aborder certains
chapitres du programme à la moindre
entorse à notre pacte républicain il
doit y avoir des décisions fortes et des
sanctions fermes et cela doit nous
conduire à revoir l'échelle des
sanctions dans nos établissements
scolaires pour ne rien laisser
passer mesdames et messieurs réussir le
réarmement civique c'est au cœur des
priorités de mon gouvernement nous
devons faire respecter l'autorité
partout dans les classe dans les
familles dans les rues ce respect
s'apprend à l'école je le disais mais ce
respect passe aussi par les familles les
violences de juillet dernier ont
profondément marqué notre pays parmi les
émeutiers des très jeunes très jeunes
parfois qui semblaient avoir déjà coupé
les ponts avec notre société qui ne
respectent plus leurs parents pour qui
la violence semble un moyen comme un
autre de tromper l'ennui je ne me
résoudrai pas à ce qu'on a préfère
attendre avant de donner une lourde
peine alors que bien souvent c'est très
tôt qu'il aurait fallu agir nous devons
disposer de sanction adapté pour les
mineurs de moins de 16 ans pour eux on
ne peut pas aujourd'hui prononcer de
peine de travaux d'intérêt général je
vous annonce que nous créerons des
travaux d'intérêt éducatif qui seront
leur équivalents et seront donnés plus
facilement que des peines d'intérêt
général cela fera partie cela fera
partie de la révision de l'échelle des
sanctions dans nos établissements
scolair que j'évoqué il y a un instant
dès le plus jeune âge il faut en revenir
à un principe clair C tu répares tu sies
tu nettoies tu défies l'autorité on
t'apprend à la
respecter nous responsabiliseront aussi
davantage les parents dans le cadre du
projet de loi sur la justice des mineurs
nous tiendront la mise en place de
travaux d'intérêt général pour les
parents de jeunes délinquants qui se
sont totalement et volontairement
soustraits à leurs obligations et
responsabilités parental mais je le dis
il est tors de question d'accabler
certaines familles quand on est une mère
seule de plusieurs enfants dans un
quartier on peut-être totalement dépassé
par les événements et on n'est pas
toujours responsable de la dérive de ses
enfants pour elle au contraire cette
dérive est un échec et une douleur
terrible nous devons les
aider
et je ne me résous pas à ce que nous
ayons une situation où nous ayons des
familles dépassées par les événements
avec des enfants qui ne respectent pas
nos règles et qui sont violents d'un
côté et 50000 places d'internat
disponibles de l'autre nous y répondrons
désormais quand un jeune sera sur la
mauvaise pente plutôt que de les laisser
plonger dans la délinquence nous
proposerons aux parents de le placer en
internat en y facilitant l'accès y
compris financier nous allons le couper
de ces mauvaises fréquentations nous
allons lui offrir un cadre un
enseignement une
chance le réarmement civique c'est bien
entendu le respect de la loi nos
concitoyens attendent de nous que nous
agissions encore et toujours contre les
violences contre les trafics contre les
cambriolages contre l'insécurité du
quotidien et la délinquence il demandent
de l'ordre dans nos rues tout n'est pas
une question de moyens il faut les
mettre au service d'une stratégie plus
offensive encore comme l'a dit le
président de la publ nous allons doubler
la présence policière dans les rues
d'ici à 2030 nous allons mener des
actions coordonnées de tous les services
de l'État force de l'ordre éducation
services sociaux dans certains quartiers
c'est le sens des forces d'action
républicaines nous les déploierons dès
la fin du mois de février dans trois
premiers territoires à Maubeuge à
Valence et à Besançon contre
l'insécurité nous nous sommes fixés deux
priorités la lutte contre les stupéfiant
et la lutte contre la délinquence du
quotidien en particulier les
cambriolages nous allons encore monter
d'un cran dans notre combat contre la
drogue en mettant en œuvre un nouveau
plan de lutte contre les stupéfiants
notre stratégie de harcèlement et de
pilonnage contre les dealer porte ses
fruits nous avons réussi à faire
disparaître un/art des points de Deal
alors nous allons poursuivre avec 10
opérations place net par semaine nous
devons aussi taper les dealers au
porte-monnaie et leur couper les vivres
c'est pourquoi nous allons désormais
geler les avoirs des trafiquants de
drogue qui sont
identifiésre CIV passe par une justice
plus rapide et plus efficace ensemble
nous allons envoyer un message clair
l'impunité c'est fini nous avons décider
de moyens exceptionnels pour notre
justice ils seront en rendez-vous pour
accélérer les délais nous allons
améliorer le fonctionnement de la
justice avec plus de magistrats plus de
greffiers avec une organisation plus
respectueuse de nos concitoyens et une
nouveauté désormais les Français ne
seront plus convoqués sur des créneaux
pouvant courir sur une demi-journée
entière mais sur un créneau horaire bien
défini c'est aussi par ce type de mesure
et de preuve de respect que l'on renoue
le lien entre la justice et les
justiciables
enfin notre réarmement civique c'est
renforcer l'unité républicaine de notre
jeunesse c'est permettre à tous les
jeunes de France de faire nation c'est
le rôle même du service national
universel je lance les travaux en vue de
sa généralisation à la rentrée
2026 mesdames et messieurs de les
députés parler de nos ice public c'est
aussi parler de nos territoires chacun
n'a pas les mêmes défis les mêmes
attentes les mêmes besoins j'évoquerai
demain longuement devant le Sénat la
stratégie sur les territoires je veux
d'ors et déjà ici puisque vous êtes
aussi élu de circonscription et pour un
bon un bon nombre d'entre élus locaux
comme moi vous dire queles sont nos
attentes mon gouvernement sera toujours
à l'écoute des territoires et des élus
locaux toutes les solutions se
construiront avec eux je peux vous
assurer aussi que nous cherchons
toujours des solutions adaptées aux
réalité du terrain en ayant recours à la
différenciation à l'adaptation des
normes nous continuerons à avancer c'est
le sens de la mission confiée à Eric
vert qui nous remettra ses propositions
dans les prochains mois nous chercherons
ensemble un chemin pour une autonomie de
la Corse dans la République comme s est
engagé le président de la République
alors que je parle de différenciation de
territoir j'ai une pensée pour les
territoires d'outreem où elle s'impose
tout particulièrement il réarmé nos
services publics il est peut-être plus
crucial plus vital encore qu'ailleurs
les outremerses sont un atout
déterminant pour notre pays il y a dans
chaque territoire d'outr-emè
l'enthousiasme de notre jeunesse la
détermination à réussir l'avenir mais
nos outremèes concentrent aussi tous les
défis contre la vie chère pour l'emploi
pour la sécurité pour la santé l'école
la lutte contre l'immigration illégale
et la transition écologique chacune de
nos politique publique doit tenir compte
des spécificités outremè j'y tiens et
pour faire face aux enjeux exceptionnels
auquels son territoire est confronté
nous déposerons une loi sur Mayotte je
veux ici avoir un mot particulier pour
la Nouvelle-Calédonie je souhaite que le
processus politique en cours aboutissse
j'y veillerai et vous examinerez dans
quelques semaines un projet de loi
constitutionnel sur l'avenir de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
ensemble je vous propose d'accélérer
encore notre transition écologique le
dérglements climatiqu ce ne sont pas
seulement quelques degrés de plus ce
sont des vies détruites par les
intempéries ce sont des exploit sttion
agricole menacé et avec elle toute notre
capacité à nous nourrir ce sont des
maisons et des immeubles menacés par la
montée des EAU fissurés par les
mouvement des sols face à ces constats
certains voudraient une écologie de la
brutalité pour eux l'écologie doit être
punitive douloureuse passer par la
désignation de Bou émissaire et par la
décroissance la décroissance je le redis
ici c'est la fin de notre modèle social
c'est la pauvreté de masse jamais je ne
l'accepterai
je crois au contraire qu'on ne fera pas
l'écologie contre le peuple je crois au
contraire qu'il faut entendre les
inquiétudes des Français de tous les
Français il faut entendre les
agriculteurs qui travaillent et qui
s'inquiètent pour leur avenir et leur
métier il faut entendre les élus locaux
qui veulent développer leur communes il
faut entendre les millions de Français
des villes moyennes des petites communes
et de la ruralité pour qui la voiture et
gage de travail et de
liberté l'écologe le peuple c'est PAV le
chemin aux crises social et au
renoncement au contraire nous allons
continuer à battir ensemble une écologie
populaire une écologie à la française
avec les Français pour les Français
c'est le sens de la planification
écologique qui protègera la biodiversité
et permettra une baisse radicale de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre une
baisse de 55 % d'ici
2030 une écologie populaire c'est une
écologie où chacun agit à la hauteur de
ses moyens c'est pour quoi l'État sera
exemplaire c'est pourquoi nous
continuerons d'aider les entreprises à
participer activement à l'effort je suis
fier que les 50 sites industriels les
plus émetteurs 50 sites qui
représentaient à eux-mêmes 10 % de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
France se soient tous engagés à réduire
leurs émission de près de moitié d'ici
2030 et je vous annonce je vous annonce
que nous lancerons une initiative
similaire contre la pollution plastique
pour les 50 sites qui mettent le plus
d'emballage plastique sur le
marché une écologie populaire c'est une
écologie des solutions le président de
la République s'était engagé à lancer
une offre de véhicule électrique pour
moins de 100 € par mois cet engagement
est tenu et le succès est déjà au
rendez-vous le président de la
République s'est engagé à développer les
RER métropolitains à investir
massivement dans le ferrt cet engagement
lui aussi nous le tiendrons une écologie
populaire c'est une écologie de la
croissance et de emploi le retour de
l'industrie les investissements en
faveur de la décarbonation grâce à
France 2030 les métiers de la rénovation
thermique ou le secteur de l'économie
circulaire oui la transition écologique
regorge d'opportunités de secteurs en
croissance de filières nouvelles oui
nous ferons rimer climat avec
croissance une écologie populaire c'est
une écologie qui se construit au plus
près des réalités des Français et des
territoires des concentrations des
concertations sont en cours partout en
France au côté des élus locaux nous
donnerons à chacun les moyens de le
faire et je souhaite que le financement
de leurs plans locaux de transition
écologique soit établi partout d'ici
l'été une écologie populaire c'est une
écologie qui protège et assure notre
souveraineté grâce à la sobriété aux
énergies renouvelables au nucléaires
nous allons assurer notre indépendance
énergétique je veux le dire sans
ambiguïé là aussi il faut être clair le
nucléaire est une fierté française
le nucléaire c'est un atout majeur pour
notre pays j'assume d'être à la tête
d'un gouvernement pro énergie nucléaire
avec une majorité pro énergie nucléaire
qui me
soutient nous allons continuer à la
montée en puissance de notre parc
nucléaire investir massivement dans les
programmes cette année le Pr de
flamandville sera opération
c'est aussi grâce au nucléair que nous
pouvons garantir les meilleurs prix aux
Français nous protégerons mieux les
consommateurs et régulerons les prix
d'électricité afin qu'il se rapproche
des coûts de production et nous
continuerons à développer les énergies
renouvelables de la même manière que
nous développerons le nuccléaire dans
notre pays
enfin mesdames et messieurs les députés
bâtir une écologie populaire c'est
répondre aux aspirations de notre
jeunesse réussir la transition
écologique est le défi de notre
génération notre jeunesse s'engager
participer aider elle le fait déjà
beaucoup d'ailleurs elle se demande
parfois comment être utile pour la
planète c'est pourquoi nous lancerons un
service civique écologique qui
rassemblera d'ici à la fin du quinquena
50000 jeunes prêts à s'engager
concrètement pour le
climat j'ajoute j'ajoute que si nous
devons réduire nos émissions et protéger
notre biodiversité nous devons aussi
nous adapter au dérèglements climatiques
nous adapter c'est nous préparer c'est
veiller à ce que chacun même les plus
fragile soit prêt face au ravage du
dérèglement climatique nous présenterons
dès ce trimestre un nouveau plan
d'adaptation au changement climatique il
présentera des solutions adaptées à
chaque territoire notamment dans les
outr-mers enfin je vous annonce que nous
ferons évoluer le régime de catastrophe
naturelle pour le moderniser et éviter
que certains assureurs n'abandonnent les
territoires les plus à
risque enfin je l'ai déjà évoqué et j'y
reviens nous devons mener notre
réarmement agricole produire et protéger
pour notre souveraineté voilà mon
approche depuis 2017 nous avons engager
ce combat de la souveraineté et du
revenu c'est le sens des plans de
filière des différentes lois igalim du
varen de l'eau nous avons débloqué 250
millions d'euros pour trouver des
alternatives au phytosanitaire c'est un
effort inédit sur l'Union européenne
nous avons toujours été moteur sur la
réciprocité et les closuses miroir et
nous les ferons respecter
produire produire produire oui ça vous
dérange produire produire c'est d'abord
donner du temps à nos agriculteurs pour
passer plus de temps dans leurs champs
moins de temps devant leurs écrans
produire c'est être souverain je
souhaite que cet objectif de
souveraineté alimentaire soit désormais
clairement inscrit dans la loi protéger
aussi protéger face aux crises
climatiques et sanitair le gouvernement
l'a toujours fait lors du gel des
sécheresses de la grippe avière nous
avons adopté un budget de l'assurance
récolte sans précédent avec un budget
historique nous continuerons à le faire
protéger face à la concurrence déloyale
c'est le combat pour la réciprocité et
pour les mesures miroires que je vais
continuer à mener avec détermination ce
combat il doit se mener en Europe comme
nous l'avons fait sur les médicaments
vétérinaires mais nous devons aller plus
loin changer de logique j'assume de dire
que tout ne sera pas réglé en quelques
semaines j'assume de dire que les
chantiers sont complexes et que pour
certains il faudra y travailler encore
j'assume aussi d'apporter des réponses
rapides partout là où c'est possible
très concrètement sur Galim dès la
semaine dernière 100 inspecteurs de la
DGCCRF supplémentaire ont commencé leurs
contrôle sur le terrain qui seront deux
fois plus nombreux qu'auparavant c'est
une vague de contrôle sans précédent sur
la trésorerie des exploitants nous
avançons dès à présent dès février 50 %
des remboursement TICPE seront versés
aux exploitants soit 733 € par exemple
pour une exploitation utilisant 7000 l
de GNR dè la semaine prochaine 5 février
précisément un guichet pour la prise en
charge des frais vétérinaires concernant
la MHE sera ouvert il permettra de
verser les premières indemnisations dès
la fin du mois de février le taux de
prise en charge des frais vétérinaires a
été révalué à 90 %. d'ici le 15 mars
toutes les aides PAC seront versées sur
les compte bancaire des exploitants et
nous travaillerons avec les
régions et nous travaillerons avec les
régions pour que les aides à
l'installation des jeunes agriculteurs
puissent être versé dans les prochaines
semaines pour certains cela fait plus
d'un an qu'ils attendent et la semaine
dernière le fond d'urgence Bretagne a
été doublé sur la simplification j'ai
parlé du travail tout à l'heure des 10
premières normes du travail au niveau
local nous allons poursuivre et nous
irons plus loin encore et tout ce que
nous pouvons le faire faire dès
maintenant nous le ferons d'ors et déjà
je peux vous dire que nous avons avancé
ces derniers jours dans la discussion
dans l'échange avec les agriculteurs et
leur représentant sur une série de
sujets sur l'élevage nous avons mis en
œuvre un dispositif fiscal qui leur
permet qui doit leur permettre de faire
face à l'inflation notamment sur les
prix de leur bêes nous le renforcerons
pour protéger toujours davantage nos
éleveurs sur égalim là c'est très clair
j'ai déjà parlé des amendes et des
contrôles mais je peux vous dire que
toutes les AM les amendes qui seront
infligées à l'industrie à la grandes
distribution seront réutilisé pour
soutenir financièrement nos
agriculteurs sur la
viticulture sur la viticulture oui nos
viticulteurs souffrent mais notre filiè
viicole et notre fierté elle fait
rayonner la France et donc je vous
annonce que nous allons déveloquer dans
les prochains jours des moyens nouveaux
avec un fond d'urgence avant la fin de
la semaine pour soutenir nos
viticulteurs particulièrement en
Occitanie sur les contrôles je lance
aujourd'hui un grand plan de contrôle
sur la traçabilité des produits
l'objectif est clair garantir une
concurrence équitable notamment pour que
les normes qu'on applique aux
agriculteurs soient aussi respectées par
les marchandises étrangères au niveau
européen nos trois priorités immédiates
sont claires les jchers les importations
ukrainiennes notamment de volaille et le
mercosour ces sujets seront portés et
sont portés très fortement par le
gouvernement et le président lui-même
nous nous sommes engagés nous avons
engager une coalition de 22 pays sur la
question déjà chers et nous sommes
proches d'aboutir à une nouvelle
prolongation de la dérogation nous ne
nous laisserons pas faire nous prendrons
toutes les mesures pour éviter toute
surtrposition d'où qu'ell viennent
je le sais nous ne sommes pas au bout du
chemin il y aura de nouvelles conquêtes
dans les jours qui viennent je pense
notamment aux jeunes agriculteurs à la
transmission des exploitations mais nous
agissons vite fort avec détermination et
respect pour nos
agriculteurs madame la Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés réarmé
la France s continué à conquérir de
nouveaux droits le président de la
République a fait de l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes la grande cause de
ces quinquen
elle sera au cœur des engagements de mon
gouvernement c'est le sens de la réforme
du congé parental annoncé par le
président de la République aujourd'hui
le congé parental ne laisse pas assez de
revenus aux familles bien souvent il est
inégalement réparti dans le couple
éloigne durablement les femmes de
l'emploi alors comme toutes les
inégalités nous devons la combattre
aussi le congé parental sera transformé
en congé de naissance de 6 mois mieux
rémunéré que les parents pourront se
répartir entre eux conquérir de nouveaux
droits c'est reconnaître et défendre
sans relâche le droit des femmes à
disposer de leur nous inscrirons le
droit à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse au sein de notre texte
fondamental de notre
Constitution conquérir de nouveaux
droits enfin c'est être au côté de nos
concitoyens jusqu'au bout de la vie la
fin de vie est sans doute l'une des
questions les plus intimes et les plus
délicates qui soit c'est se pencher sur
son histoire c'est repenser aux
souffrances enduré par certains c'est
s'interroger sur soi-même sur ce que
l'on voudrait face à l'insupportable et
à l'irréversible face à l'irréparable on
ne peut légiférer sur la fin de vie
qu'avec une grande prudence grande
retenue et un grand respect aujourd'hui
nos compatriotes clairement nous
appellent à revoir notre droit c'est une
demande des famille c'est une demande
des malades c'est un appel grave auquel
nous devons répondre nous y répondrons
nous renforcerons considérablement les
unités de soins palliatifs dans notre
pays avec une unité par département
avant l'été nous examinerons un projet
de loi sur l'aide active à mourir dans
notre pays ce débat animera notre
société je le sais je souhaite qu'il
puisse se tenir dans une volonté
d'équilibre et dans le respect des
convictions de chacun madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés je viens de tracer les grandes
orientations que suivra mon gouvernement
en suivant ce chemin je propose aux
Français d'avoir pleinement le contrôle
sur leur vie je souhaite que la France
retrouve pleinement la maîtrise de son
destin qu'elle soit pleinement
souveraine une souveraineté industrielle
technologique et numérique CR créatrice
d'innovation et d'emploi une
souveraineté énergétique qui nous
protègera des crises protègera
l'environnement et garantira des prix
plus bas aux Français une souveraineté
agricole qui nous permettra de nourrir
notre pays avec les meilleurs produits
d'assurer l'avenir de notre agriculture
et dans les tous prochains jours j'aurai
des annonces supplémentaires à faire sur
le sujet une souveraineté culturelle où
notre création notre patrimoines sont
soutenu où notre exception culturelle
est protégée où la culture est enfin
accessible à tous mesdames et messieurs
les députés je parle de souveraineté
nationale mais c'est aussi par l'Europe
que nous parviendrons à la
consolider depuis 2017 et le discours de
la Sorbonne du président de la
République l'Europe a changé elle a
surmonté les crises pris ses
responsabilités c'est grâce à l'Europe
que nous avons pu avoir des vaccins face
à l'épidémie grâce à l'Europe que nous
avons bénéficié du plan de relance
c'est grâce à l'Europe que nous
soutenons l'Ukraine depuis le premier
jour face à l'agression russe grâce à
l'Europe que nous avons imposé des norme
au géants du numérique grâce à l'Europe
que nous avons instauré un impôt minimal
sur les grandes sociétés multinationales
pour lutter contre l'optimisation
fiscale grâce à l'Europe que nous
contrôlerons mieux nos frontières grâce
au Pact asile immigration un pacte que
je résume en une phrase nous
contrôlerons enfin qui peut entrer dans
l'espace Schengen et qui ne le peut pas
grâce à l'Europe aussi que nous
investissons mass dans CS seeurs
stratégiqu et pour notre industrie je le
dis ceux qui prent la fin de
l'application des traités sont les
partisans d'un fr exit déguisé qui
affaiblirait la
France
moins d'Europe moins d'Europe c'est
moins de puissance pour la France je ne
prendrai qu'un exemple il fera mal à
certains ici le brexit ces partisans
promettaient des jours heureux à
l'économie britannique et au peuple
anglais la semaine dernière à cause du
brexit les derniers au fourneau de
Grande-Bretagne ont fermé on ne produit
plus d'acier au Royaume-Uni nous en
France au contraire notamment grâce aux
investissements de l'Europe l'industrie
revient qui était qui était les premiers
partisans en France du brexit qui a
baptisé dans les villes qu'il dirigent
des rues rues du brexit qui s'est
affiché ouvertement avec le leader du
camp du brexit c'est le rassemblement
national l'Europe l'Europe éternel B
bouémissaire de ceux qui fautent de
pouvoir diriger un pays veulent détruire
tout un continent pas un Français ne
pense que nous pouvons nous passer
d'Europe pas un français non plus ne
pense que l'Europe a su pleinement
trouver la juste place dans sa vie ils
ont raison tout n'est pas parfait il
reste des chantiers à mener mais les
faits sont là avec l'Europe notre
puissance est démultiplié et ces
dernières années nous avons commencé à
la
changer et je le dis solennellement à
l'heure où il est minuit Mo- une dans le
siècle face au impérialismes les masques
devront tomber on peut vouloir changer
l'Europe pour l'intérêt du pays et nous
le faisons mais on ne peut pas vouloir
sortir de l'Europe sauf à avoir d'autres
intérêts sauf à servir un autre pays une
autre
puissance
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés voilà les grands
principes qui guideront mon action celle
de mon gouvernement pour la France et
pour les français pour notre France qui
n'a jamais perdu son ambition de
grandeur pour ces Français qui n'ont
jamais manqué à leur devoir ces axes que
je vous ai présenté ils sont une réponse
aux enjeux de la nation probablement pas
la seule mais le reflet de l'ambition
que nous portons avec le président de la
République il correspondent aussi au
rêve qu'une génération avait appris à ne
plus porter trouver un emploi stable
acheter un logement fonder une famille
faire des sacrifices mais acceptables
s'ils servent à l'ascension de leurs
enfants aimer les paysages une culture
commune une société libre et tenue dans
une époque si difficile il n'y a pas de
réponse simple mais il y a des espoirs
tranquilles à raviver j'assumerai
toujours toujours de débattre avec vous
je respecterai toujours vos opinions vos
propositions je ne rejetterai jamais la
critique tant qu'elle est constructive
ces mots ces mots je les adresse à vous
je les adresse aussi aux Français je
sais leurs attentes je sais qu'ils ne me
pardonneront rien les temps sont
troublés les doutes sont nombreux mais
l'espoir est
là la France est puissante parce que ce
qui nous réunit est toujours plus fort
parce que la France notre pays notre
nation notre terre demeureront notre
fierté parce que oui être français en
2024 oui c'est une fierté notre société
est plus ouverte plus audacieuse plus
pionnière que l'image que nous nous
renvoyons parfois à nous-mêmes
être français en 2024 c'est vivre dans
un pays où l'histoire s'écrit être
français en 2024 c'est vivre dans un
pays qui n'a pas renoncé au progrès
social à protéger les droits de tous et
surtout de toutes et en conquérir de
nouveau être français en 2024 c'est
vivre dans un pays dont l'honneur est de
se battre pour la stabilité du monde
pour la justice et pour la paix être
français en 2024 c'est dans un pays
quiil y a 10 ans seulement se déchirit
encore sur le mariage pour tous pouvoir
être Premier ministre en assumant
ouvertement son homos
sexualité de tout cela je vois la preuve
que notre pays bouge la preuve que les
mentalités évolue la preuve que nous
n'avons aucune raison de céder à la
fatalité alors je n'ai qu'une chose à
dire à nos concitoyens quelle que soit
leur couleur de peau leur origine leur
adresse leur croyance la France est
votre pays et en France tout est
possible madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés oui nous sommes
fiers d'être français et avec vous je
veux faire briller cette fierté
française je viens de vous présenter le
cap de mon gouvernement le cap pris sous
l'autorité du Président de la République
pour reprendre pleinement notre destin
en main et restaurer notre souveraineté
et aujourd'hui nous sommes prêts prêts à
voir la vérité en face prêt à écouter
prêt à entendre la voix de tous les
Français prêt à agir prêt à œuvrer sans
relâche fidèle à notre devise
républicaine prêt à garantir la liberté
à œuvrer pour plus d'égalité à toujours
choisir la fraternité parce que Madame
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés nous ne sommes pas n'importe
quel pays nous ne serons jamais une
puissance moyenne qui se résignerait au
déclin avec fatalité nous ne sommes pas
condamnés à subir mais déterminés à agir
déterminés à prendre notre destin en
main déterminés madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés parce
que nous sommes la France et que rien ne
résiste au peuple
français
merci beaucoup monsieur le Premier
ministre
merci
beaucoup je vous
remercie la
parole est à monsieur le Président pour
le groupe
[Applaudissements]
merci de quitter l'hémicycle en silence
pour ceux qui nous
quittent madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Premier Ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues j'ai l'honneur d'être le
premier orateur après votre prise de
parole monsieur le Premier ministre et
votre intervention confirme ma première
impression votre talent votre énergie
est un atout dans la période que nous
[Applaudissements]
traversons et je pense
que nous sommes prêts à passer tous les
caps avec vous pas simplement le
caporne pour quelqu'un de ma
génération la nomination d'un jeune
premier ministre a quelque chose de
rassurant pour
l'avenir lorsque je me suis engagé en
1974 pendant la campagne de giscar vous
n'étiez pas né monsieur le Premier
ministre et bien d'autres avec Marielle
de sarneise
notamment j'ai été
saisi du même sentiment en 2017 avec le
président de la République et
aujourd'hui avec votre arrivée à
Matignon je ressens un peu ce même
mouvement cette même ardeur et j'ai
envie de dire
chich le discours que vous venez de
prononcer s'inscrit sur ce chemin du
dynamisme qui incarne l'esprit 2017
les Français avaient alors choisi
l'optimisme l'ouverture et les valeurs
démocrates ce sont ces valeurs que vous
représentez et je vous sais conscient de
la responsabilité qui vous incombe
conscient de la hauteur de la tâche qui
est la vôtre et que vous abordez avec
l'audace et la détermination nécessaire
en étant précis et attentif aux attentes
concrètes des Français le groupe
démocrate que j'ai l'honneur de présider
vous fait confiance pour que vous soyez
fidèle à cette méthode fidèle à vos
valeurs pour mettre en œuvre une
politique volontariste et réformiste
vous avez été élu pour la première fois
en même temps que nombre d'entre nous
vous êtes en quelque sorte l'un d'entre
nous nous avons confiance en vous et en
la promesse que vous venez de faire de
travailler en étroite collaboration avec
le Parlement la transformation de notre
pays notre groupe vous accompagnera dès
lors que vous nous proposerez de
travailler main dans la main pour des
réformes utiles et justes à ce moment de
mon intervention per permettez-moi
d'envoyer un signe d'amitié et de
respect envers ellisabeth bornne qui a
su conduire notre majorité depuis
[Musique]
2022 de façon utile et constructive je
veux ici la remercier pour tout ce
qu'elle a donné à notre
pays Monsieur le Premier Ministre vous
le savez vous y avez participé beaucoup
de réformes ont été engagées depuis 2017
pour favoriser l'économie d'entreprise
et l'emploi nous avons lancé de grands
chantiers les lois SOC Pact élan etgalim
mais il faut reconnaître que par la
force des crises les gilets jaunes la
crise sanitaire la guerre en Ukraine
nous avons beaucoup paré à l'urgence
sans nous projeter avec vigueur dans
l'avenir force de constater également
que la France de 2024 n'est plus la
France de 2017 la guerre est désormais
sur notre sol les catastrophes climatiqu
deviennent plus récurrente et brutal que
jamais et l'accession des pouvoirs des
populistes au des populistes dans de
nombreux pays du monde renversent les
anciens équilibres le monde le moment
est venu de rebondir d'être à
l'offensive et vous venez de le prouver
au groupe démocrate nous demandons des
grandes lois structurantes sur le long
terme avec de la programmation la
sécurité juridique t les lois de
programmation de la défense la justice
ou la police sur des marqueurs sociétaux
sur lesquels nous pourrions retrouver
l'adhésion de nos concitoyens dans cette
nouvelle méthode le groupe démocrate
vous accompagnera avec ce que nous
sommes déterminé à redonner de la force
à notre pays lui rendre sa souveraineté
rendre les Français fiers de constituer
une nation unie et solidaire nous avons
nombreux défis à surmonter et je veux
avant tout vous apporter ainsi qu'à
votre Ministre de l'Agriculture Marc fen
notre plein soutien pour résoudre la
crise agricole
actuelle cette crise est multiforme et
le reste des sujets que nous avons les
tout autant comment
réindustrialiser le pays pour créer des
emplois et assurer notre souveraineté
comment accueillir les travailleurs dans
un territoire quand on a pas de logement
pour les accueillir avec leurs familles
comment répondre à l'exigence de
simplification sans vererser dans le
tout numérique la mauvaise calibration
du guichet unique montre qu'il nous faut
faire confiance aux tiers que nous avons
besoin de maintenir le contact et le
succès des maisons de Fran serv est à
cet égard très parlant comment demander
aux Français d'assurer le renouvellement
des générations quand il est impossible
de trouver une pièce en plus pour loger
des enfants à naître comment redonner
confiance quand la solidarité
l'ascenseur social l'école sont en perte
de vitesse quand la culture est réservé
à certains seulement comment prendre en
charge nos aînés soigner les Français
tous quel que soit le territoire dans
lequel il réside voilà les défis qui
sont devant nous et notre devoir est de
répondre à l'ensemble de ces questions
en les menant de franc ensemble en
tenant compte des deux éléments
fondamentaux la crise environnementale
qui doit guider l'ensemble de nos
politiques et la crise préoccupante de
nos finances publiques vous avez
beaucoup insisté monsieur le Premier
ministre sur le travail qui celui qui
rémunère celui qui fait vivre une
famille vous parlez du travail qui
émancipe et làdessus nous sommes avec
vous faciliter les formations les
embauches pour les entreprises leur
simplifier pour qu'il passe plus de
temps à chercher de nouveaux marchés ou
déposer des brevets plutôt qu'à faire de
la paperasse nous devons également nous
interroger sur notre fiscalité qui n'est
plus adapté au monde actuel agissons
contre les inégalités qu'elles soient
sociales économique ou environnementales
sans pour autant briser les talents vous
savez aussi Monsieur le Premier Ministre
notre grande préoccupation face à la
crise du logement et de l'immobilier
pour nous groupe démocrate le logement
est l'un des fils rouges de l'égalité
des chances de la naissance au derniers
jour le logement plutôt que de
représenter la première des inégalités
doit être un lieu d'émancipation alors
oui il faut absolument bâtir une
politique du logement cohérente humaine
et adapté à la société d'aujourd'hui les
solutions existent même si elles passent
par quelques bouversement y compris
fiscaux certains États du monde ont
compris que pour réussir il fallait
gouverner à 30 ou 40 ans à en France
nous avons parfois pris l'habitude de
gouverner à 30 ou 40 jours cela ne peut
plus fonctionner notre horison doit être
celui de la génération il en est de même
dans d'autres domaines tels que la
démographie année après année nous
voyons les naissances se tasser sans
réagir aujourd'hui nous avons un
indicateur de fécondité au plus bas
depuis la Seconde Guerre mondiale hormis
en 93 et 94 cette question démographique
ne doit pas être prise à la légère elle
est cruciale crucial pour l'avenir de
notre nation notre contrat social qui
fait la richesse de la France repose sur
cet indicateur il font nos politiques de
santé d'éducation nos politiques de
solidarité agir pour la progression
démographique suppose d'abord et avant
tout de combattre une totale
détermination avec une totale
détermination les inégalités é radiquer
les inégalités de destin celles qui font
que lorsqu'on est dans un certain
quartier dans un certain milieu social
sur sous certain nom de famille on y est
condamné à vie il faut une politique
familiale et une protection de l'enfance
ambitieuse comme ce que nous avons bâti
depuis 6 ans la création d'une
délégation au droit de l'enfant au sein
de notre assemblée est en est une belle
illustration l'éducation ensuite qui est
le cœur même de l'émancipation de tous
les élèves tous les élèves doivent se
prévaloir des mêmes chances dans toutes
les écoles meilleur suivi des élèves des
classes à taille humaine le métier de
professeur revalorisé tels sont les
chantiers sur lesquels nous avons
commencer à travailler ces dernières
années et que nous devons poursuivre
avec davantage de vigueur nous savons
tous ici que la réussite du système
éducatif dépend surtout du bien-être de
l'accompagnement et du nombre de
professeurs encourageons les vocation
mettant en œuvre une vraie politique de
formation aidons les à s'installer dans
tous les territoires au-delà un autre
défi et non des moindes nous attend
celui du vieillissement massif de la
population qui entraîne des défis
immenses explosion des dépenses de
protection sociale besoin d'aménagement
de la vie quotidienne notamment en
matière de logement nouvelles exigen des
services publics en termees d'assistance
et de soins je souhaiterais aussi
aborder vous l'avez un petit peu fait
monsieur Premier ministre les défis des
territoires je parle de tous les
territoires l'Hexagone bien évidemment
mais également tous nos territoires
d'outrem qui méritent une attention
forte du gouvernement maintenir notre
modèle économique et social suppose de
mener une politique volontariste de
réduction des des inégalités
territoriales l'une des fractures les
plus fortes réside dans l'accès au soins
sur les déserts médicaux le comp pas
malgré tous nos efforts soutenons les
médecins volontaires pour aller dans des
zones oubliées l'ouverture d'une
numérosclausus est actée mais reste
insuffisante l'exigence d'égalité
territoriale c'est aussi l'accès au
services publics avec une administration
qui aide plutôt que de traquer et punir
et c'est enfin en soutient à notre
agriculteur à nos agriculteurs comment
accepter qu'après les lois égalim nous
en soyons toujours même constat nos
agriculteurs qui nourrissent par leur
force de travail les Français n'arrivent
toujours pas à vivre décemment leur
activité il reste coincé dans le fossé
de la grande que la grande distribution
a largement creusé entre le consommateur
et le producteur vous venez encore de
faire encore à l'instant de faire de
fortes propositions qui viendront
s'ajouter au grand texte à venir sur le
renouvellement des générations je
souhaite qu'elle soit de nature à
répondre enfin à ce malêtre agricole
profond mais là encore toujours avec une
vision à long terme voici Monsieur le
Premier Ministre que nous croyons ce que
nous esp on pouvoir faire avec vous dans
un contexte de grand boueverersement le
plus grand bouversement nous l'avons
tous en tête le dérèglement climatique
avec la question du pouvoir d'achat les
fractures territoriales l'inflation il
est de plus en plus difficile de faire
accepter à nos concitoyens des
changements dans leur mode de
consommation alors que ce renforce
l'impérieuse nécessité d'agir et et fort
pour et fort d'agir vite et fort pardon
pour produire nos émissions pour réduire
nos émissions de gaz effet de serre la
question la plus délicate est donc de
savoir qui finance la transition
énergétique et comment faire en sorte
que les Français ne subit pas ne
subissent pas cette transition c'est un
enjeu important Monsieur le Premier
Ministre auquel vous allez devoir vous
atteler car si nous sommes tous
convaincu que l'urgence est là nous ne
devons pas assister impuissant à la
dégradation du vivant notre partenaire
le plus important sur ce sujet comme sur
l'agriculture la défense la solidarité
la santé sera une nouvelle fois l'Union
européenne 2024 sera l'année européenne
et j'ai confiance dans tous les
démocrates pour mettre toutes leur force
dans la campagne des valeurs européennes
la liberté l'État de droit l'égalité la
solidarité et c'est encore plus
important face au grand bouleversement à
l'échelle internationale dont je le
crains nous n'avons pas encore
véritablement pris la pleine mesure ce
sont bien évidemment les conséquences de
la situation Moyen-Orient la détresse et
les souffrances du peuple ukrainien ou
encore les incertitudes liées aux
élections
américaines ce qui se joue est donc de
renforcer de consolider l'Union
européenne les Européens doivent
défendre leurs valeurs et leur mode de
vie ils ne pourront le faire que s'ils
s'unissent face aux grands risques
mondiaux nous avons d'autres nous
n'avons d'autre choix que de nous
préparer nous
Européens défendre nos valeurs
européennes et démocrates cela implique
aussi de changer de méthode dans notre
hémicycle monsieur le Premier ministre
je le disais au début de mon propos
votre nomination nous rappelle l'esprit
de 2017 et renoué avec 2017 c'est aussi
renoué avec le dépassement dépassement
des clivages des antagonismes des
postures dépassement au fond de nos
vieilles habitudes le groupe démocrate
défend depuis longtemps l'importance de
moins légiféré pour mieux légiférer en
travaillant sur moins de textes mais des
textes plus structurants
mieux évaluer aussi l'efficacité des
politiques
publiques je sais bien sûr que nos
difficultés sont aussi liées à notre
mode de scrutin premier germe de la
division ainsi nous devons nous poser
cette question pour raviver notre
démocratie tout cela implique de faire
des efforts de davantage respecter nos
différences plutôt que de les cultiver
ce sont les qualités qui prévalent au
groupes démocrate et qui s'est construit
sur l'unité la positivité l'écoute la
liberté le dépassement de conflit par le
rassemblement des valeurs c'est dans
l'ADN du groupe du Mouvement Démocrate
d'avoir une vision sociale démocrate et
humaniste et nous serons à vos côtés
Monsieur le Premier Ministre pour la
faire vivre je vous
remercie je vous remercie monsieur le
Président merci
beaucoup
merci la parole est à monsieur le
Président vot pour le groupe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
socialiste
oui comme ça tu sais
bien monsieur le Premier ministre nous
connaissons votre bilan c'est celui du
président de la République la crise du
logement la crise de l'hôpital la crise
agricole la crise de l'école la crise
sociale la crise des salaires la crise
des finances publiques c'est la réforme
de l'assurance chômage la réforme du RSA
la réforme des retraites c'est aussi ce
moment coupable de bascule politique et
morale avec la loi immigration lorsque
vous avez cédé à la droite et à
l'extrême droite nous connaissons
désormais votre projet c'est celui du
président de la République libéral et
conservateurs la cohabitation assumée
avec la droite dont vous conduisez
désormais la politique nous pourrions
longemp parler de vous mais je veux
parler des Français car notre rôle
d'opposition c'est de convertir l'alerte
en perspective et la critique en action
les Français souffrent le pays souffre
et le mal qui le ronge c'est
l'injustice alors que vous préparez déjà
une nouvelle réforme du marché du
travail et de l'assurance chômage faite
de mauvais coupt vous prétendez défendre
la valeur travail nous défendons pour
notre part la valeur du travail et nous
voulons que la valeur change de camp
qu'elle ne soit plus du côté des
rentiers des actionnaires et des
rémunérations extravagantes mais du côté
du travail et des travailleurs nous
défendons la France des rond-points des
sous-préfectures vous défendez la France
du rond-point des Champs-Élysées nous
voulons que le travail paye et qu'il
paye bien pas de cette France de
travailleur pauvre nous défendons
l'égalisation de la fiscalité du capital
et du travail la taxation des
multinationales et des super profits un
juste partage de la valeur pas vous nous
défendons l'augmentation des salaires
indexés sur l'inflation une limitation
des écarts de rémunération de 1 à 20 pas
vous nous voulons que la valeur soit du
côté de l'utilité sociale l'heure est
venue d'une radicale reconsidération
morale et économique des métiers du soin
nous avons besoin plus que jamais des
infirmières des aides à domicile des
assistants d'éducation des aides
soignantes nous voulons bâtir un modèle
économique pour le 21e siècle où le
travail est mis au service de la pleine
santé vous parlez d'emploi nous voulons
parler de travail des conditions de
travail de santé au travail du temps de
travail et du temps libéré de
l'organisation du travail et des
processus de production le temps de
travail et le travail comme mise en
commun et but partagé nous défendons
pour cela le dialogue social le dialogue
professionnel et la codétermination dans
l'entreprise ce dont il faut se
débarrasser ce n'est pas du travail les
gens aiment leur métier mais des
rapports de domination vous voulez
libéraliser ubériser le travail nous
voulons toujours mieux le civiliser nous
défendons le travail qui émancipe digne
et porteur de
sens vivre dignement c'est aussi pour
beaucoup de nos compatriotes compter sur
nos services publics si durement
attaqués par vos réformes quand les sa
social de service public reculent les
inégalités avancent et les injustices
prospèrent les Français les plus
modestes sans interlocuteur au prise
avec des services sociaux chamboulés par
l'austérité fragilisé par par vos
réformes toujours suspicieuses en sont
comme toujours les premières
victimes ce qui caractérise le présent
et plus encore l'avenir c'est
l'incertitude qui trie les vies et qui
laisse les plus fragiles sur le bord du
chemin ce que nous devons imaginer ce
sont les services publics de demain et
c'est une protection sociale qui
apprivoise le hasard l'état social de
demain c'est celui du retour à
l'universel qui n'oublie pas les
catégories et les classes moyennes qui
trop souvent ont le sentiment de de
n'avoir droit à rien c'est-à-dire des
services publics étendus pour tous des
droits et des mécanismes de solidarité
qui sont notre capital commun
l'universel ce sont des droits pour tous
plutôt que des allocations pour certains
l'universel c'est l'extension des
services publics et leur gratuité comme
dans les transports publics par exemple
l'universel c'est l'assurance maladie
obligatoire à 100 % pour tous c'est l'UM
minimum jeunesse et le repas à 1 € c'est
demain la sécurité sociale alimentaire
et la garantie universelle des yer c'est
aussi une réflexion exigeante sur la
gestion de nos biens communs la terre
l'eau leur partage et leur accaparement
ce qui doit être laissé ou retiré au
marché comme les épades ou les crèches
l'universel je voudrais y insister
devant votre Ministre c'est la mixité
sociale à l'école la ségrégation mine la
cohésion national aboudissant au REP sur
soi pour les uns et à la séession pour
les autres nous devons avoir un objectif
supérieur étudier ensemble pour vivre
ensemble car seule l'expérience est
universalisante et ce n'est pas votre
SNU qui remédiera à des années de
séparatisme social l'instruction
publique reste indubitablement le ciment
de la République contre toutes les
grandes féodalités sociales religieuses
économiques et territoriales mais aussi
contre toutes les forces de la désunion
nationale c'est comme cela que l'on
ramène à la République par la République
et je
aux obsudés du réarmement civique et de
la régénération aux inquiets de la
décivilisation la République sociale
c'est au fond la meilleure façon de
prendre en charge le sentiment national
c'est la seule voie pour se monter
l'éterlem dilemme entre la recherche de
l'universel et l'affirmation du
particulier la République c'est ce qui
nous distingue et pour nous une forme de
vie collectitive fondé sur la recherche
de l'égalité comme base des relations
sociales et comme mode de production du
commun
généreux de mots nous avons entendu et
avar d'acte votre bilan environnemental
est un dépôt de bilan jamais la crise
n'aura paru ni plus tangible ni plus
violente ni portter aussi nettement son
cortège d'injustice et d'inégalité
tandis que prospè des richesses et des
modes de vie incompatibles avec les
limites de la planète ajoutant au
sentiment d'incompréhension et de colère
la justice comme objectif et comme mode
d'action est pour nous l'un des leviers
majeurs de la transformation sociale est
la seule façon de repenser les
fondements mêmees de notre politique
économique elle redonne sa légitimité à
la puissance publique sa nécessité à la
planification écologique sa force au
débat
démocratique alors que nos paysans
souffrent chacun le sent l'agriculture
ne traverse pas une simple crise elle
est au cœur d'une révolution à la
confluence de la critique du libéralisme
elle est au cœur de la contestation de
de l'exigence de justice et de
l'impératif écologique ce qui sombre
c'est une organisation
socio-industrielle fondée sur l'énergie
à Bakou la chimie l'agrandissement des
structures la spécialisation et un libre
échange destructeur pour ouvrir une
nouvelle ère il faut une refondation de
la PAC à Bruxelles et une vraie loi
d'orientation à Paris nous n'avons ni
l'un ni l'autre un cap l'agroécologie et
le renouvellement des générations un
impératif le juste partage de la valeur
face à la prédation de la grande
distribution et des industries agroal
aire une condition la protection de nos
marchés contre une mondialisation
déloyale il n'est plus possible de faire
semblant nous avons besoin d'une grand
d'un grand plan de bifurcation
écologique des investissements de
l'ordre de 100 milliards d'euros par an
financés par une caisse d'amortissement
de la dette climatique nous voulons un
plan de réindustrialisation et de
décarbonation de notre industrie garant
de notre souveraineté industrielle et
alimentaire nous devons défendre nos
intérêts souverains préparer l'avenir et
construire l'industrie de demain avec
les ouvriers d'aujourd'hui nous voulons
nous engager résolument dans la
décarbonation de nos modes de vie
planifier les besoins énergétiques
massifier la rénovation thermique
soutenir l'investissement dans les
réseaux et les énergies renouvelables
senir soutenir le transport ferroviaire
et fluvial notre écologie monsieur le
Premier ministre c'est l'écologie des
vulnérables une écologie à hauteur
d'homme de la vie quotidienne qui
dessert la ceinture des plus modestes
mieux se loger mieux se déplacer mieux
se nourrir nous voulons avec avec les
Français plus de justice et moins de
carbone partout dans le monde Monsieur
le Premier Ministre la dénonciation de
l'injustice l'urgence écologique et le
combat démocratique sont intimement liés
depuis 7 ans l'exécutif n'a cessé de
mépriser le dialogue social de
brutaliser le Parlement d'ignorer les
aspirations profondes des Françaises et
des Français le président de la
République par sa pratique personnelle
aura fini d'épuiser la 5e République et
d'abîmer la politique dans ce que les
citoyens lui conservit encore de crédit
il aura manqué de ce type de murs de
vertu de scrupulle de sens civique de
respect de l'adversaire qui fond de la
démocratie le président de la République
a oublié les conditions de son élection
face à l'extrême droite toute concession
est une faute morale toute tentative de
triangulation une erreur tactique la
réaction menace garde-nous qu'elle se
serve un jour de l'ordre républicain
pour le retourner contre la République
elle-même monsieur le Premier ministre
il n'y a qu'un pas de la faiblesse à la
trahison ce pas vous l'avez
monsieur le Premier ministre après 7 ans
de macronisme les socialistes sont
épuisés jamais le défi inégalitaire
n'aura été plus grand ni le ni l'idéal
républicain d'émancipation si lointain
les inégalités explosent les injustices
multiplie les frontières
infranchissables et invisibles quand les
incertitudes sont fortes que l'avenir
apparaît sans issue l'entreçoi devient
un refuge chacun défend sa colère et sa
vision du monde il existe un autre
chemin un autre idéal pr par venir tout
n'est pas à refaire tout n'est pas à
abattre tout est en Trô main et je veux
dire le sens profond de notre projet et
de notre opposition abattre les barrière
qui partout s'oppose à la fraternité
humaine on me dira que la fraternité pas
un projet politique c'est le seul qui
vaille pour sortir les hommes et les
femmes de la solitude dans lesquell les
laissre votre politique votre œuvre
destructrice Monsieur le Premier
Ministre abandonne les plus faibles à ce
que vous pensez être leur destin de
perdant je vous ai écouté vous êtes le
jeune visage du vieux monde
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
la parole est à monsieur le Président
marcangéi pour le groupe
horizon madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Premier Ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues je
m'adressais à vous il y a un an et demi
au début de notre mandat en soulignant
la difficulté de la tâche qui nous
attendait je vous faisais part d'une
conviction celle selon laquelle nous
vivons un instant décisif de la vie de
notre pays force de constater que je
peux reprendre ces termes devant vous
pour décrire la situation actuelle crise
inflationniste crise agricole crise
géopolitique crise démocratique nous
sommes toujours à cette croisée des
chemin nous assistons jour après jour à
la complexification du qui nous entoure
les défis à relever sont donc toujours
aussi
nombreux néanmoins et en dépit d'une
situation politique
inédite nous avons fait adopter plus de
50 textes tous nécessaires depuis
l'élection de cette assemblée nous avons
su trouver des consensus quand c'était
possible et des compromis quand ça
nétait pas les années qui viennent ne
seront utiles au pays que si nous fixons
un cap clair ce cap c'est celui du une
France plus juste et plus prospère pour
le plus grand nombre c'est ce qui a
guidé l'action de chaque premier
ministre depuis 2017 et je veux ici
saluer l'action d'Édouard Philippe Jean
Castex et ellisabeth
borne Monsieur le Premier Ministre les
espoirs et attentes de nos concitoyens
sont immenses la tâche pour ne pas les
décevoir est d'autant plus
ardue comme avec votre prédécesseur vous
trouverez les députés du groupe horizon
et apparenté à vos côtés pour travailler
dans le sens de l'intérêt général
partenaire sérieux partenaire loyal mais
partenaire exigeant c'est ainsi que nous
concevons d'accompagner votre action
gouvernementale nous devrons apporter
des réponses rapides mais pérennes sur
plusieurs sujets prioritaires que je me
permettrai de décliner dans la suite de
mes propos surtout ces solutions ne
porteront leurs fruit que si elles sont
de bon sens nous croyons fermement que
l'immense majorité des Français souhaite
en réalité de la Justice de la
simplicité et de
l'efficacité depuis quelques jours les
revendications agricoles nous rappellent
à quel point de nombreux Français se
sentent abandonnés dans l'époque qui est
la nôtre ils s'y sentent d'ailleurs pour
beaucoup d'entre eux parfois prisonniers
il désespèrent de la qualité de nos
débats publics et ne manque pas de nous
le faire savoir aussi je demande à
chacune et à chacun de sortir de ces
certitudes en regardant la France telle
qu'elle est et non pas telle qu'on
voudrait qu'elle soit l'actualité
récente nous démontre que la
surtransposition de normes est une bombe
à retardement pour les secteurs qui la
subissent les injonctions
contradictoires le dénigrement du
travail les règles imposées en dépit du
bon bon sens font le malheur de notre
pays et en particulier de notre
agriculture si nos sols et nos
savoir-faire sont une grande et belle
puissance agricole ne les prenons pas
pour acquis il nous faut à tout prix
éviter que l'agriculture française
connaisse un déclin similaire à celui de
la sidérurgie au siècle dernier nous
saluons donc les mesures annoncées par
le gouvernement elles vont dans la bonne
direction je dis cela sans renier rien
de notre engagement pro-européen nous
voulons bien sûr une Europe qui
s'affirme davantage sur la scène
mondiale une Europe au service de ses
citoyens mais aussi une Europe qui ne
crée pas de contraintte excessive ni de
concurrence déloyale la question de la
juste rémunération de nos agriculteurs
pourrait d'ailleurs se poser dans
d'autres domaines le travail doit payer
c'est une question de bon sens et c'est
même l'un des fondement de notre contrat
social je pense à ceux qui cumulent les
heures de travail parfois les emplois et
n'arrivent pas à boucler les fins de
mois ce sont les mêmes qui souvent
ressentent une pression fiscale accrue
qui n'est pas compensée par les
contreparties offertes par notre système
sociale la société du travail doit être
notre boussole travailler dur doit
permettre à nos citoyens d'augmenter
d'améliorer leur niveau de vie de telles
situations génèent un sentiment
d'absence de considération auquel nous
devons remédier notamment en faisant en
sorte qu'il soit toujours préférable de
travailler que de ne pas travailler
cette considération il faut qu'elle soit
la même à Paris aussi bien qu'à carbone
à Sevran ou à ajaco en garantissant un
accès au service public en luttant
contre les déserts médicaux en
désenclavant les territoires par une
offre de mobilité adaptée et en assurant
hors et sécurité pour chacun la mobilité
c'est de pouvoir changer de lieu
d'habitation et de ne pas subir une
forme d'assignation à résidence or la
crise du logement est là et elle
n'épargne personne elle concerne d'abord
l'accès à la propriété avec des
acheteurs potentiel qui font face à une
hausse des taux d'intérêt et dans le
même temps une baisse des crédits
accordés par les banques initialement
créé pour répondre à ce besoin le
logement social ne tient plus sa
promesse républicaine c'est donc une
double peine pour la majorité de nos
concitoyens qui sont exclus des
logements sociaux tout en étant
confrontés à des prix sur le marché
libre bien au-delà de leur capacité en
un mot la crise du logement nous oblige
à une réponse rapide globale et de long
terme faire preuve de bon sens c'est
aussi investir pour l'avenir pour notre
jeunesse en poursuivant nos efforts au
service de l'éducation nos professeurs
sont aujourd'hui mieux rémunérés et nous
sommes rentrés dans une nouvelle ère
face au harcèlement scolaire celle de la
tolérance zéro mais beaucoup reste à
faire en particulier sur le plan du
respect de l'autorité de cette
institution et du corps enseignant je
sais Monsieur le Premier Ministre votre
attachement à ce ministère qui fut le
vôtre là encore vous pourrez compter sur
nous cette capacité av voir loin pour
nos enfants se traduit aussi par la
prise en compte de l'urgence écologique
dans l'ensemble de nos politiques
publiques le cycle des événements
climatique extrême s'accélère et trouble
laquiétude des habitants de notre pays
au côté du ministre Béchu nous prenons
une écologie pragmatique fondée sur le
réalisme et toujours de bon sens en
matière climatique comme ailleurs nos
arbitrages devront prendre en compte le
sentiment d'étau dans lequel se sent
pris une grande partie de nos
concitoyens nous devons être attentif
aux conséquences qu'auront les hausses
inéluctables des factures énergétiques
et environnementale avenir les prochains
textes que nous serons amenés à voter
devont prendre cette réalité en compte
et permettre à la France de tenir son
objectif de neutralité carbone à horizon
2050 au-delà de la protection de la
planète et de la biodiversité je veux
rappeler notre engagement pour la
protection des Français en matière
militaire de justice et de sécurité
trois lois de programmation historique
ont été votées par le Parlement en un an
elle dote notre pays d'une trajectoire
claire concernant le fléchage des
dépenses dans des champs régaliens
stratégiques sur plusieurs années
modernisation de nos armées plus de
recrutement dans la justice plus de
forces de l'ordre sur le terrain c'était
là des attentes de longue date du peuple
français nous veillerons également à la
poursuite de notre politique fiscale et
à la mise en œuvre dès 2025 comme vous
l'avez annoncé Monsieur le Premier
Ministre de la baisse de 2 milliards
d'euros d'impôts pour les classes
moyennes afin que le travail paye pour
paraphraser Jacques Chirac la feuille de
paix ne doit pas être l'ennemi de
l'emploi de là seulement naîtra la
compétitivité l'innovation et donc la
prospérité les députés du groupe horizon
et apparenté resteront toutefois
vigilants sur le fait que chaque dépense
soit fin
afin de mettre un terme à la croissance
de la dette publique et ainsi préserver
notre souveraineté budgétaire et
financière sujet d'intérêt pour notre
groupe la réforme de notre système de
santé doit se poursuivre personne sur
ces bancs ne peut se satisfaire qu'une
grande partie de nos concitoyens soit
privé d'une offre de soins accessible
dans un délai raisonnable le groupe
horizon et apparenté l'a déjà affirmé
c'est aux acteurs locaux d'organiser
l'offre de soins en fonction des besoins
de chaque
territoire si la baisse de la natalité
nous inquiète à juste titre il faut
aussi se préoccuper du vieillissement de
notre population autre grand enjeu de
notre siècle la proportion des plus de
50 ans est amené à doubler d'ici 50 ans
ce n'est rien de moins que la
soutenabilité de notre système de santé
qui est en jeu pour cette raison nous ne
pourrons pas faire l'impasse sur une loi
dédiée au grand
âge l'année 2024 sera enfin et c'est
suffisamment peu courant pour s attarder
une année de révision constitutionnelle
je fais partie de ceux qui pensent qu'il
ne faut modifier la Constitution clé de
voûte de notre République qu'avec une
main tremb
certains changements apparaissent
pourtant nécessaires compte tenu de
l'évolution de notre société la
consécration deinterruption volontaire
de grossesse comme droit garanti pour
toutes les femmes tout d'abord l'avenir
de la nouvelle calédonnée ensuite et
plus personnel le statut d'autonomie de
la Corse que vous avez évoqué lors de
votre discours monsieur le Premier
ministre monsieur le Premier ministre
vous l'aurez compris le groupe horizon
et apparenté souhaite que notre pays
retrouve du bon sens notre programme de
travail est chargé
pour peu de temps utile notre programme
éclaire soyons efficace parlons de fond
trouvons le consensus faisons
disparaître ce sentiment de mépris
source de notre affaiblissement
démocratique vous pouvez compter sur
nous notre groupe loyal mais exigeant
sera à vos côtés pour faire réussir la
France je vous remercie merci beaucoup
monsieur le
Président la parole est à madame la
Présidente châelin pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Premier Ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues Monsieur le Premier Ministre
vous venez il y a quelques instants de
proclamer votre discours de politique
générale vous avez posé les priorités de
votre gouvernement avec l'emphase qui
vous caractérise là et tout votre talent
donnerz l'impression du mouvement alors
que tout reste figé d'ù ventreementra de
l'action de l'action de l'action saturer
l'espace médiatique de déplacement de
mise en scène de petites et de grandes
annonces espérant que cela nous fasse
oublier l'état de la France les services
publics qui s'effondrent les Français
qui s'appauvrissent le climat qui se
détériore votre rôle se réduit donc à
faire office d'écran de fumée mais les
actes ont des conséquences après c
années au pouvoir cette année agir au
sein de la majorité et dans les
gouvernements successifs d'Emmanuel
Macron permettez-moi Monsieur le Premier
Ministre de vous jugeer non sur vos
paroles mais sur votre politique
commençons par votre bilan face au péril
climatique sous l'effet de l'activité
humaine le climat s'emballe si rien ne
change la terre se réchauffera de 3
degrés d'ici à 200 et loin d'agir les
États se complaisent dans un statut quo
qui nous mène à la catastrophe la France
ne fait évidemment pas exception le 10
mai 2023 le Conseil d'État exhortait
votre gouvernement à prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour garantir la baisse de
40 % des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre d'ici 2030 inscrite dans la loi et
vous que faites-vous vous supprimer les
nouveaux objectifs climat l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie appelle à
renoncer dès maintenant à tout nouveau
projets pétrolier ou gazier dans le
monde et vous vous refusez de stopper
huit nouveaux forages en Gironde la la
monde est entrée dans l'air des
catastrophes climatiques le nordp
decalis subit des inondations la Réunion
le cyclone Bellal la France entière les
vagues de chaleur et vous vous soutenez
des projets autoroutiers anachroniques
tel la 69 la 6e extinction de masse sera
bientôt une réalité dans notre pays et
vous vous consacrez 0,14 % du budget de
l'État à la biodiversité et des tricoter
le code de l'environnement la ressource
en eau pourrait diminuer de 40 % d'ici à
2050 et vous vous refusez les objectif
de réduction du prévèement de l'eau pour
l'industrie vous avez volontairement
capitulé face face au réchauffement
climatique pourtant les conditions
vitales de l'existence ne se négocient
pas c'est pourquoi les écologistes sont
au côté de celles et ceux qui luttent
pour notre survie qui démentantellent
les projets climaticides et qui
désarmment les multinationales les
écologistes continueront à défendre des
politiques environnementales ambitieuses
la loi de programmation pour la
rénovation thermique le droit d'accès à
la nature ou encore la sortie des
énergies fossiles Monsieur le Premier
Ministre votre politique est finalement
très cohérente vous défendez ceux qui
s'accapar la terre tout comme vous
encouragez ceux qui s'acapar les
richesses d'ailleurs bien souvent ce
sont les mêmes voici donc les
conséquences très concrètes de votre
politique un enfant sur C vit dans la
pauvreté un Français sur 4 ne mange pas
à sa fin un Français sur 10 a renoncé à
se soigner de Français sur 10 n'arrivent
pas à payer leur facture à temps et vu
vos annonces ils vont être nombreux à se
serrer encore davantage la ceinture
pourtant pour trop de nos citoyen la vie
se rétrécit pas de vacances pas de petit
plaisir seulement travail et facture et
vous avez volontairement capituler face
aux inégalités car soyons honnêtes vous
n'avez jamais cherché à les combattre
vous êtes arrivé au pouvoir persuadé et
je vous cite la France sououffre
davantage d'inégalité de destin que
d'inégalité de revenus oui combattent
les inégalité de destin c'est donner à
chacun les moyens de s'émanciper de
s'épanouir grâce à l'éducation la
culture le sport c'est de combattre pied
à pied le séparatisme des riches c'est
de donner à l'enseignement public les
moyens financiers et humain de mener à
bien sa mission offrir à tous les
enfants de France l'opportunité
d'apprendre d'aguiser leur esprit
critique et de grandir tout simplement
mais qui peut croire un instant qu'on
peut combattre les inégalités de destin
en laissant croître les inégalités de
revenus les opportunités ne sont pas les
mêmes pour les 10 % des Français les
plus pauvres qui qui dis pose pour tout
patrimoine de quelques milliers d'euros
sur un livr a et pour les 10 Français
les plus riches qui détiennent en
moyenne un patrimoine de 1,1 million
d'euros disposer d'un patrimoine élevé
ce n'est pas seulement une protection
financière c'est le droit à l'erreur
c'est le droit de prendre son temps le
temps d'hésiter de se construire de se
découvrir nous proposons donc l'évidence
non pas de tout taxer mais de reprendre
au profiteurs de remettre les super
profits au pot commun et d'instaurer un
ISF climatique l'argent magique n'existe
pas le ruissellement spontané non plus
il est de votre responsabilité de
garantir la juste répartition des
richesses pour gagner contre les
inégalités il faut mener une bataille
féroce contre ses plus grands
adversaires l'accaparement et le
surprofit là encore force de constater
que vous avez volontairement capitulé
vous parlez d'autorité de sanctions
contre les jeunes contre les chômeurs
contre les précaire globalement contre
les Français mais par contre vous
manquez de courage quand il faut s'en
prendre au cupides aux multinationales
dont les marges sont bandit durant la
crise car ell spéculent sur la guerre
ell spéculle sur les impacts des
catastrophes climatiques pour faire face
aux actionnaires qui font des plus
valalue sur la difficulté des Français
et considèrent les énergies fossiles
mortifères comme une machine à cach
pendant que la planète
étouffe total réalise plus de 19
milliards d'euros de bénéfice pendant
que les agriculteurs se démett la
fortune des trois frères qui possèdent
l'ctalis représente 43 milliards pendant
que les Naves fréatiques s'achèchent les
actionnaires de NESTLE se sont partagés
19 milliards de dividendes le système
marche sur la tête pour preuve en un an
les prix de l'alimentation dans les
magasins on augmenté de 8 % pendant que
les prix d'achat aux agriculteurs a
baissé de 9 %. les seuls gagnants les
seuls gagnants ce sont les industries
agroalimentaires dont les marches sont
passé en un an de 20 28 % à 48
% c'est pour ça que naturellement les
écologistes sont solidaires du mouvement
des agriculteurs sont solidaires de leur
lutte pour vivre dignement depuis 30 ans
les écologistes se battent contre les
accords de libre échange qui les
soumettent à une concurrence déloyale
revendique un revenu minimum souhaite
réformer la PAC et supprimer la dette
qui offpress ses
exploitants Monsieur le Premier Ministre
votre seule réponse est de réduire les
protections environnementales ces normes
qui protège la santé de nos paysans et
les terres qui cultivent une réponse
inadaptée qui n'affronte pas l'AGR
business choisir la facilité ne résoudra
rien la crise ne sera pas enrayée et le
déclin de l'agriculture française
continuera en bref depuis 7 ans vous
avez activement volontairement siamment
capitulé face aux profiteurs des crises
alors mettons un mot sur votre politique
posons les mots et parlons d'égoïsme
pour un gouvernement qui enrichit une
minorité au détriment du reste de la
nation posons les mots et parlons
d'impunité quand le président décide
d'utiliser son statut l'autorité de
l'institution qu'il représente la
visibilité dont il bénéficie pour
écraser la parole des femmes victimes
d'hommes considéré comme intouchable
posons les mots et parlons de déchéance
morale après l'adoption de la loi
immigration qui reprend les obsessions
et les mensonges de l'extrême droite
alors que ces ministes défilent dans nos
rues à Lyon à H romens surisire posons
les mots et parlons d'incompét quon vous
êtes incapable depuis un mois de nommer
un ministre du Logement et qu'au vu de
vos annonce vous allez encore fragiliser
le logement social et que vous annoncez
tout au plus 30000 logements dans 20
territoires alors qu'il en faut
500000 le 9 janvier dernier vous vous
adressiez monsieur le Premier ministre à
nous votre opposition en ces termes nous
avons en commun le destin de notre
nation sur ce point nous nous retrouvons
les décisions que nous prenons ici et
maintenant façonnerons notre destin
commun et celui de nos enfants tout
d'abord soyez assurés que nous votre
opposition de gauche écologiste
défendons ensemble dans cette assemblée
une politique de progrès social et de
justice climatique ensemble nous avons
voté la hausse du smique la prime
alimentaire l'interdiction de substances
cancérigènes l'interdiction des jets
privé et vous vous y êtes
systématiquement opposé pour que notre
destin soit grand pour que notre destin
soit beau c'est un changement radical
dont nous avons besoin car vous
capitulation successives ont amoindri la
France la France doit reprendre son
souffle elle doit aussi reprendre sa
place dans le concert des Nation la
France était une boussole au niveau
international cette parole écoutée a été
abîmée par la présidence d'Emmanuel
Macron alors que la Cour internationale
de Justice alerte sur le risque de
génocide à Gaza la place de la France
est claire elle doit être du côté du
droit de la raison de la paix et de la
vie la France doit activement uvrer
pour le retour des otages et doit exiger
fermement un cesser le feu immédiat et
permanent Victor Hugo définissait la
France de 1789 comme une grande lumière
mise au service d'une grande justice
nous écologiste nous battrons sans
relâche pour que la France redevienne la
nation qui Luse de manière acharnée
contre les inégalités nous nous battrons
pour que la France se dresse enfin
contre l'accaparement des terres et de
l'eau que la France reste une terre
d'accueil qui protège et qui nous rend
fier nous continuerons à nous battre
pour une certaine idée de la France la
France qui ose la France qui n'a pas
peur la France qui s'entraide malgré
vous malgré vos annonces rétrogrades
nous continuerons à faire vivre la
lumière de la
France merci beaucoup madame la
[Applaudissements]
Présidente la parole est à présent à
monsieur le Président chassigne pour le
groupe Gauche démocrate et
républicaine
madame la Présidente et chers collègues
monsieur le Premier ministre lors de sa
réélection en avril 2022 face au
rassemblement national le président
Macron avait déclaré ce vote m'oblige
pour les années à venir depuis cet
engagement n'a trouvé d'écho ni dans la
politique
ni dans la pratique du pouvoir les
élections législatives avaient pourtant
confirmé la nécessité pour le camp
présidentiel privé de majorité absolue
de gouverner autrement et de
rééquilibrer les pouvoirs le mandat de
Madame borne s'est au compter inscrit
dans la continuité de pratiqu brutal
avec pour pratique nouvell 23 493 et
s'il fallait attribuer une palme elle
serait décernée au 493 qui s'est abattu
sur la réforme des retraites mad malgré
l'opposition de 80 % des Français et de
la majorité de
l'hémicycle violence institutionnelle et
renimement des engagements tel est le
résumé de ce début de quinquena qui
s'est achevé en donnant à l'extrême
droite une victoire idéologique majeur
en séd dans toute honte bu au fantasme
avec l'adoption d'un texte sur
l'immigration contraire à la loi
fondamental en créant un appel d' au
racisme tout en fragilisant notre État
de droit certes plus d'une trentaine de
mesures ont été censurées par le Conseil
constitutionnel mais l'irréparable a
déjà été commis laissant derrière son
passage blessure et conséquences
monsieur le nouveau Premier ministre
vous êtes non seulement comptable de ce
triste bilan mais vous avez été désigné
comme commissaire politique par le
Président de la République pour
poursuivre l'œuvre entamée le 16 janvier
dernier il vous a rappelé que le Dét
suprême du pouvoir exécutif c'est
lui vous venez de le confirmer avec
votre gouvernement mondain de l'entre
soi vous servirez sa politique au
service des riches une politique qui
creuse toujours d'avantage les
inégalités avec fierté dites-vous sans
jamais douter avec arrogance c'est cette
feuille de route qui vous a été confié
et la vacance de temps de ministère de
votre gouvernement àeste de la
quintessence idéologique de ce projet
politique alors que l'hôpital public se
meurt que le non accès au soins est
généralisé laissant pas moins de 6,7
millions de personnes sans médecin
traitant ce gouvernement ne compte pas
du ministère de la Santé de plan
exercice à nombre alors que le nombre de
travailleurs pauvres et d'emplois
précaires explose que les réformes
successives et celleavenir menace
l'existence même d'un droit à
l'assurance chômage ce gouvernement ne
compte pas de ministère de travail de
plein exercice alors que la France
traverse une crise du logement d'une
ampleur inédite que le nombre de
personnes sans domicile a doublé en 10
ans que 3000 enfants dorment dans la rue
que 18 % de la population vit dans un
logement insalubre ce gouvernement ne
compte toujours pas de ministre de
logement alors alors que Lady outremer
le
taux de chômage est de à qu fois plus
élevé que dans l'Hexagone que si nourrir
y coûte 30 à 42 % plus cher que s'il
trouve les plus grands déserts médicaux
et que le scandale d'État du clord DESC
atteint la réponse de votre gouvernement
toujours pas de portefeuille dédié à ces
territoires alors que notre pays a
besoin de mesures choc pour développer
le transport ferroviaire les transports
en commun à la hauteur des besoins dans
l'urgence de la transition écologique ce
gouvernement ne conque pas de ministre
des Transports alors que l'école
publique qu'on est une crise sans
précédent que près de 10000 enseignants
ont disparu depuis 2017 que la France
poursuit sa chute vertigineuse dans le
classement PISA pas de ministère de
plein d'exercice pour éducation
nationale pire le jour même de sa
nomination la ministre en charge de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse des
sports des Jeux Olympiques et
paraolympique vter la ségrégation
sociale et le tri social humiliant au
passage les enseignant du
public votre message monsieur le Premier
ministre est clair le règne de
l'éritocratie est désormais assumé et le
triomphe de l'oligarchie assurée alors
que les guerres bouleversent l'ordre du
monde que l'urgence à l'action pour la
paix nous constatons la mise sous
tutelle deun ministre des Affaires
étrangères qui dit avoir pour seul at
tout d'avoir grandi à l'étranger pour
réussir dans sa tâche au combien
difficile il est essentiel pour le
rayonnement de la France à
l'international où sont vos propositions
pour réparer notre République abîmée
pour apaiser notre pays déchiré pour
répondre à la souffrance de la majeure
partie du peuple maltraité face au
désespoirs agriculteurs vous avez fait
le Paris du coup de com sur un ballot de
paille mais vos annonces sont pas
convaincu pas plus que celle
d'aujourd'hui et pour cause aucune
mesure sérieuse pour répondre sur la
durée à la situation catastrophique
qu'ils affrontent rien rien de concret
sur les distorsions de concurrence
nourrie par l'importation massive de
produits qui ne respectent pas les
normes sociales ou sanitaires rien sur
les effet du libre échange des traités
de libre échange des assignés seulement
un vague engagement sur le mercosour en
ignorant les autres négociations en
cours rien sur le revenu des
agriculteurs les prix planchés et sur la
révision en profondeur du cas des
négociations commerciales je vous le dis
on ne dupe pas impunément ce qui ne
veulent pas mourir pour pouvoir nourrir
et vous ne duperez pas non plus la
majorité des Françaises et des Français
qui ne se laisseront pas impressionner
par une litanie de mesurettes de court
terme alors qu'ils attendent des
réformes de fond et de progrès social
face à une inflation qui atteint 20 % en
cumulé sur les deux dernières années
avec des pics encore plus importants
pour les denraises alimentaires et
l'énergie face à la smigartisation de la
France face à la paupérisation des
travailleurs vous ne proposez rien pour
revoir de fonte en comble notre système
fiscal et garantir une meilleure
répartition des richesses et de la
valeur rien rien pour réduire les écarts
de revenus rien rien pour pénaliser la
rente financière améliorerif
effectivement le niveau de vie de
l'immense majorité de nos concitoyens
bien au contraire vous nous annoncez
poursuivre dans la casse minutieuse de
notre modèle social vous allez laisser
respirer les entreprises avec moins de
norme et étouffer les chômeurs avec
moins de droit et vous avez oublié comme
par hasard de rappeler l'augmentation
des prix d'électricité et des franchises
médicales je vous le demande monsieur le
Premier ministre solennellement renoncer
à ces
augmentations face au drame qui se
déroule en Palestine et alors que la
Cour internationale de Justice a reconnu
le risque de génocide en cours dans la
bande de Gaza la France comme vous-même
reste désespérément silencieuse et
complaisante à l'égard du gouvernement
israélien
ignorant le rôle que notre pays pourrait
jouer dans cette région pour retrouver
de sa grandeur passée vous
persistez dans votre refus de
reconnaître l'état
palestinien à appeler in cesser le feu
permanent mais vous précipitez pour
suspendre les aides à l'uneras et au
réfugiés
palestiniens le fameux deux poids de
mesure est devenu la ligne de conduite
de la diplomatie française enfin vous
nous assurer vouloir être respectueux de
la représentation nationale mais
n'est-ce pas vous monsieur le Premier
ministre qui avez inventé le 4 mai
dernier de concert avec votre Ministre
de tutelle Monsieur le Maire
l'obstruction gouvernementale pour
empêcher l'adoption de notre proposition
de loi pour indexer la DGF sur
l'inflation n'est-ce pas vous Monsieur
le Premier Ministre l'hypertrophie
présidentielle associé à la servitude de
l'exécutif et à votre pratique de la
démocratie parlementaire ne nous laisse
que peu d'espoir Monsieur le Premier
Ministre votre refus de soumettre vos
déclarations de politique générale au
vote de la représentation nationale an
néanti à lui seul tous vos efforts
déployés à convaincre des atouts de
votre jeunesse pour diriger ce
gouvernement vous enavez la fougue mais
il vous manque le plus essentiel le
courage et le panache pour ce qui
concerne les députés du groupe GDR
communistes et progressistes des
territoires dit d'outrem nous resterons
fidèles aux engagements que nous avons
pris devant les Françaises et les
Français dans le combat entre l'ombre et
la lumière nous nous opposeront au
sabotage méthodique des valeurs qui ont
fait la grandeur de notre pays et de
notre République indivisible laïque
démocratique et social nous resterons
fidèles à notre pratique parlementaire
travaillant sans relâche ici sur nos
territoires et sur nos territoire pour
être au plus près des besoins et des
préoccupations de celles et ceux qui
souffrent nous déplirons toute notre
énergie pour réparer notre nation parce
que nous sommes pour reprendre des m
céser du côté de l'espérance mais d'une
espérance conquise lucide hors de toute
naïveté oui hors de toute naïveté ce qui
nous fait dire pour conclure tchur
sortez du corps de notre premier
ministre parce que comme le dit le poète
quand on est réaque on est
réque je vous remercie monsieur le
président parole est à présent à
monsieur le Président Pancher pour le
groupe liberté indépendant outre ma et
territoire madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Premier Ministre mesdames messieurs
les ministres chers collègues comme la
plupart des collègues du groupe Liot je
suis allé sur un barrage d'agriculteur
en colère ces derniers jours pour leur
témoigner notre solidarité notre soutien
mon passage n'était ni organisé par des
services de la préfecture ni filtré issu
d'un territoire rural fils d'agriculteur
ayant à l'esprit les graves difficultés
qu'ils affrontent et qui n'ont fait que
croître j'ai vu les visages graves comme
pour les professionnels de santé les
artisans ou les enseignants j'ai été
frappé par une colère amplifiée par
l'absence d'écoute et de
concertation après la crise des gilets
jaunes celle des retraites des banlieux
cette mobilisation c'est encore et
encore un appel à changer les modes de
décision et une soif de transformation
de notre L logiciel
démocratique vous n'anticipez jamais et
vous ne savez pas écouter vous êtes dans
l'entre soi depuis les beaux quartiers
de Paris coupé de la réalité de nos
territoires que nous demandent nos
concitoyens que le travail pai enfin et
que vous maîtrisiez l'inflation touchant
de plus en plus de Françaises et de
français en difficulté mais aussi une
justice et un accompagnement social et
non pas marche ou crève comme il m'a
semblé l'entendre il y a quelques
instants de la simplification le stock
des normes a triplé en 20 ans des normes
qui s'additionnent se contredisent
mettre fin à la technocratie en folie
enfin un état qui se consacre qui se
concentre sur ses priorités seul 6 % de
l'investissement sur le régalien on
comprend mieux pourquoi nos hôpitaux la
justice l'enseignement nos commissariat
sont dans un aussi mauvais état et que
l'on ne prépare pas l'avenir de nos
jeunes y compris au plan environnemental
cette crise institutionnelle ne peut pas
se ne peut se résoudre que par une
réforme profonde de l'État la priorité
un véritable choc de décentralisation
plus de consultation avec le référendum
un parlement plus respecté décords
intermédiaires plus écouté des dépenses
publiques les plus importantes de tous
les pays occidentaux chez nous et des
services publics qui fonctionne de moins
en moins bien quel
paradoxe les Français attendent des
mesures fortes sur le pouvoir d'achat le
partage de la valeur ajoutée et de la
participation ils veulent des hôpitaux
qui fonctionnent des épates qui ne
soient pas des mouroirs et des bonnes
écoles qui ne soient pas réservé qu'aux
plus riches comme le président s'était
engagé nous demandons une vraie loi
grand âge une vraie politique du
logement permett aux Français de se
loger soutenir la construction s'engager
enfin dans la rénovation énergétique
mais par une politique du logement en
regroupant et en simplifiant tous les
dispositifs la seule réponse enfin une
prise en compte des territoires
ultramarins comme nos territoires ruraux
toujours oubliés et négligé nous
demandons une véritable loi de
programmation pour nos territoires
ultramarins les coupures d'eau sont
insupportables comme les difficultés
d'accès aux soins d notamment à la
double insularité je ne vous ai pas
entendu non plus monsieur le Premier
ministre sur l'aménagement des
territoires vous venez de prononcer
votre discours de politique générale 3
semaines après votre nomination un
catalogue en oubliant petit détail que
vous n'avez toujours pas de majorité
votre gouvernement n'est toujours pas
constitué vous n'avez pas osé d'ailleurs
demander la confiance de notre assemblée
vos déclarations choc les surenchères
médiatiques et leur mise en scène où les
réponses à l'immédiateté des réseaux
sociaux ne seront contentés nos
concitoyens à la recherche d'un CAP un
véritable développement enfin humain
économique sociale et environnementale
et par une méthode claire celle de
l'écoute et de la
concertation mais cela fait 7 ans que
vous êtes au pouvoir et même si cela
fait déjà 7 ans que vous êtes au pouvoir
il n'est jamais trop tard pour bien
faire pour travailler sur les priorités
pour notre pays ces trois prochaines
années nous y sommes prêts pas une liste
à la prêverre pour associer tous les
corps intermédiaires et les forces vives
de notre
pays nous vous demandons un calendrier
précis sur les réformes
institutionnelles le transfert de
compétences y compris réglementaires aux
grandes collectivités et leur autonomie
fiscale c'est la clé de la réussite pour
la France sans oublier la question de
l'autonomie pour la Corse nous croyons
dur comme faire monsieur le Premier
ministre que notre pays n'est pas
ingouvernable que notre pays est
réformable et que et rien n'est
inéluable sous réserve enfin que vous
entendiez les Françaises et les Français
avec le président Macron vous êtes
maintenant au pied du mur il y a deux
portes la première vous permettra de
monter un à un tous les escaliers du
redressement de notre pays à condition
de le faire dans la concertation la
deuxième s'ouvre face à un grand
précipice un saut qui sera pour notre
pays sans parachute écoutez Monsieur le
Premier Ministre écoutez les Françaises
et les Français et surtout ne vous
trompez pas de
porte merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président la parole est à présent à
monsieur le Président maard pour le
groupe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Renaissance rien
encore madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Premier Ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres
alors que vous prononcez devant cette
assemblée votre discours de politique
générale il est clair que 2024 sera une
année
décisive pour pour notre continent
d'abord avec la tenue d'un scrutin qui
déterminera l'Europe que nous
voulons pour notre pays ensuite alors
que les Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
de Paris feront rayonner la France à
travers le monde pour notre avenir enfin
puisque les politiques que nous aurons à
voter et à mettre en place dès
maintenant définiront le visage de notre
nation pour les décennies à venir c'est
dans ce contexte plein d'enjeux et de
défi que vous avez été nommé monsieur le
Premier ministre et cette nomination
symbolise pour les députés Renaissance
autant une marque de renouvellement que
de
fidélité de fidélité oui à l'égard de
cette majorité parlementaire dont vous
êtes issu cette majorité qui en 7 ans a
créé 2 millions d'emplois et fait de
l'objectif du plein emploi un but
atteignable et non un vœux
pieux cette
majorité cette majorité qui est celle
qui a entamé la réindustrialisation de
notre pays avec l'installation de plus
de 300 nouvelles usines sur notre
territoire celle qui investit dans notre
souveraineté énergétique en relançant
notre filière nucléaire et en
développant les énergies renouvelable
comme jamais auparavant celle qui a
permis un renfoncement des effectifs de
notre police et de notre justice dans
des proportions inédites depuis 30 ans
et redonner à nos armées les moyens
d'assurer leur mission aux quatre coins
du
globe c'est cette majorité qui a accru
l'égalité des chances dans le
dédoublement des classes et l'école
inclusive et qui lutte depuis 7 ans
contre les déserts médicaux avec la
suppression du numéros closus et la
libération du temps médical mais nous
devons aller plus loin
vous avez fait Monsieur le Premier
Ministre des annonces fortes devant nous
celles qui ont su protéger nos
concitoyens et nos entreprises lors de
la crise du covid-19 comme nous les
protégeons encore aujourd'hui face à
l'inflation plus qu'aucun autre pays
européen cette majorité qui a fait de la
France le premier pays d'Europe en terme
d'investissement tout en accélérant la
transition écologique avec la baisse de
plus de 4 % de nos émissions de CO2 en
oui 4 % nous sommes dans la
trajectoire celle qui a voté les moyens
de protéger notre souveraineté
alimentaire avec les lois égalimes j'y
reviendrai je pourrais multiplier j'y
reviendrai je pourrait multiplier les
exemples de notre action résolue depuis
7 ans pour libérer pour protéger et
transformer notre
pays Monsieur le Premier Ministre vous
vous inscrivez dans notre dans cette
histoire et vous avez désormais
avec votre gouvernement à en écrire une
nouvelle page et vous avez d'emblé voulu
vous inscrire sous la prime sous le
prisme de l'action et du
concret c'est une nécessité tant la
politique risque de mourir de ce
paradoxe celui de ne pas oser dire les
choses d'un côté et de l'autre d'en dire
trop au risque de se perdre dans le
discours au détriment des
actes plus que tout les temps que nous
vivons impos que nous soyons dans le
faire davantage que dans le dire dans
l'action plutôt que dans
l'incantation Monsieur le Premier
Ministre parce que nous partageons le
même constat nous attendons de vous que
votre action prenne toujours en compte
la réalisation du dernier
kilomètre celui sans lequel il n'est pas
concevable de pouvoir changer réellement
la vie des
Français vos paroles devant cette
assemblée et vos premières décisions
constituent une preuve de l'importance
que vous accordez à cet impératif
et il aura s'incarner dans les nombreux
domaines qui définiront la France de
demain l'un des plus essentiel pour
notre pays premier producteur européen
c'est bien sûr l'agriculture dans un
monde aux échanges ultra
compétitifs nous devons continuer à
défendre l'excellence des produits
français en imposant les mêmes normes de
qualité aux pays qui veulent importer
leur denrée chez nous les députés
Renaissance veulent ces clauses miroir
pour qu'il soit impossible d'importer
des produits qui ne correspondent pas à
nos normes et nous
saluons et nous saluons votre
détermination à les instaurer dans nos
échanges
commerciaux c'est cette préoccupation
d'une alimentation de qualité qui nous a
posé poussé à déposer une proposition de
loi sur le bien manger qui sera votée
ici dans cette assemblée en mars
prochain mais pour que notre agriculture
prospère il faut avant tout que ceux qui
la font vivre puisse vivre de cette
activité sans craindre le lendemain pour
cela en tant que législateur nous ne
pouvons tolérer que les lois votées par
la représentation nationale soi
contourné voire
bafoué aussi nous saluons votre volonté
de faire respecter par les distributeurs
les transformateurs et les industriels
les lois égalime ainsi que la loi que
nous avons porté pour sécuriser
l'approvisionnement des Français en
produit de grande
consommation nous serons à vos côtés
pour défendre l'agriculture exiger
qu'elle soit rémunérée à sa juste
valeur et nous continuerons dans les
semaines à venir à nous faire le relais
des préoccupations des maréchers des
éleveurs des viticulteurs des céréaliers
de l'ensemble des agriculteurs et des
pêcheurs de nos
territoires pour porter des textes qui
améliorent leur quotidien tel que la
proposition de loi renaissance pour
protéger le mode de vie agricole face au
troubles du voisinage dans cette
perspective nous nous appliquerons à
enrichir toujours plus la future loi
d'orientation agricole et apporter des
mesures qui changeront concrètement et
rapidement la situation de ceux qui nous
nourrissent ce choc des facilités que
nous voulons pour notre agriculture il
doit aussi se faire au bénéfice de
l'ensemble des concitoyens et des
entreprises de notre pays sans oublier
les collectivités
locales la bureaucratie est un poison
lorsqu'il alimente le désordre au lieu
de le
résoudre à la suite de la crise du covid
nous avons commencé à lever certaines
lenteur à remettre en cause des
procédures sans logique c'est cet élan
qu'il nous faut conserver dans la
nouvelle loi de
simplification nous serons évidemment au
rendez-vous pour l'amender et
l'accentuer ce chantier de la
simplification nous permettra ainsi de
modifier profondément la vie de nos
concitoyens tout en maintenant notre
objectif de redressement des finances
publiques la bonne tenue de nos comptes
est un impératif absolu de notre
majorité et nous tiendrons ensemble
monsieur le Premier ministre le
désendettement que nous nous sommes
fixés cette trajectoire que nous sommes
fixés jusqu'en
2027 plus que tout pour permettre à
notre pays de prospérer il faut vous
l'avez martelé dans votre discours
redonner toute sa pertinence à la valeur
travail d'abord en faisant en sorte que
le travail paye et en refusant de
laisser des millions de salariés
s'enfoncer dans la
précarité nous ne pouvons tolérer que
ceux qui respectent notre contrat social
et contribuent chaque jour à faire
tourner nos entreprises connaissent les
angoisses des fins de mois cette classe
moyenne qui est le pilier de notre
économie et qui se sent trop souvent la
grande oubliée de nos politiques
publiques à cet égard les mesures que
vous avez annoncé ici Monsieur le
Premier Ministre vont dans le bon sens
car le travail doit toujours payer plus
que
l'inactivité ce combat pour le travail
il est au cœur du projet que les députés
Renaissance défendent depuis 7 ans car
il est l'essence même de l'émancipation
de chacun et il sera déterminant pour
améliorer durablement le pouvoir d'achat
des Français qui est leur principale
préoccupation et qui doit donc être la
nôtre en métropole comme en outre
MRE essentiel aussi dans cette quête
d'émancipation est l'accès pour tous à
un logement or la crise que connaît
actuellement ce secteur impose que nous
apportions des réponses fortes aux
Français les texte que notre groupe a
porté ces derniers mois qu'il s'agisse
de la proposition contre l'occupation
illicite celle sur les meublés
touristiques constituent des premières
briques nous playons depuis longtemps
pour franchir un cap un véritable choc
de l'offre vous le savez Monsieur le
Premier Ministre vous étiez attendu sur
ce sujet vous y avez répondu par des
annonces
fortes un autre impératif un droit
fondamental même c'est le droit à la
sécurité aucun habitant ne devrait
craindre de se promener dans son
quartier aucune femme devrait craind de
rentrer seul le soir aucun citoyen ne
devrait être victime d'incivilité voire
de violence dans l'espace
public aucun Français ne devrait
craindre de représaill du simple fait de
sa confession à tous nous devons leur
assurer quel que soit leur lieu de
résidence leur genre ou leur religion
qu'il puissent vivre en paix dans leur
pays les députés renaissan y
contribueront dès ce printemps avec une
proposition de loi renforçant la réponse
pénale contre les infractions à
caractère raciste ou antisémite et un
autre allongeant la durée de
l'ordonnance de protection pour les
victimes de violence
conjugale j'ai commencé à énumérer les
chantiers de court terme mais je
n'oublie naturellement pas ceux qui ont
vocation à s'inscrire dans le temps long
car ils sont au fondement même de notre
identité parmi eux le premier bien sûr
l'école car c'est auprès des jeunes
génération que se joue notre avenir des
jeunes générations à qui monsieur le
Premier ministre vous avez d'emblé dit
que vous vouliez redonner des cause
d'espérance nous ne pouvons qu'y
souscrire pour cela l'école est
primordiale et pour lui redonner toute
sa place nous devons jamais oublier
hésiter à changer ce qui doit l'être à
bousculer les schémas lorsqu'ils sont
imparfaits à donner les moyens à nos
enseignants aux établissements de
valoriser ce qui
fonctionne cet investissement du
il faut qu'il se traduise dans tous les
services publics partout sur les
territoires notamment en matière de
santé car la première cause du sentiment
d'abandon de beaucoup c'est le manque
d'accès aux soins je l'ai dit notre
majorité a déjà agit pour inverser la
tendance et comme vous l'avez souligné
dans votre discours il nous faudra
accentuer cet effort nous serons à vos
côtés pour
cela un autre défi de notre temps le
plus grand sans doute c'est le
changement climatique vous avez en
responsabilité Monsieur le Premier
Ministre la exposer la planification
écologique ce sera essentiel pour
promouvoir une écologie de l'innovation
et de solution plutôt qu'une écologie de
l'obligation l' l'écologie doit rimer
avec ambition écologie ne doit jamais
rimer avec décroissance
nous ne devons pas abandonner notre
ambition écologique mais celle-ci ne
doit jamais se faire au détriment des
Français il faut aussi redonner aux
citoyens le goût de l'engagement c'est
ce que notre majorité s'emploie à faire
en votant cette semaine la proposition
de loi visant à soutenir l'engagement
bénévole ainsi que la proposition de loi
visant à reconnaître les métiers de la
médiation
sociale votre décision de pérenniser les
cours d'éducation civique à l'école
constitue également un signe
extrêmementcourageant de même la
généralisation du SNU que vous venez
d'annoncer ce besoin d'engagement il se
fait aussi sentir dans notre démocratie
cela impose de revaloriser ceux qui la
font vivre il n'est pas concevable que
dans notre pays les élus soi impunément
l'objet d'insulte de menac de de
violence pour ne pas dire de
l'inchage servir concitoy au sein de sa
commune de son département de sa région
ou dans cette assemblée ne devrait
jamais faire craindre pour sa vie ou
pour celle de ses proches une démocratie
qui se retourne contre ceux qui la
servent elle se détruit et honte à ceux
qui par leur comportement outrancier ont
pu y compris sur ces bancs alimenter ses
bas
instincts à cet égard la proposition de
loi renforçant la sécurité des élus
locaux sera
salutaire car le retour de l'autorité
passe nécessairement par le respect
envers les institutions et leurs
représentants pour mener à bien toutes
ces entreprises l'esprit de compromis
qui exige la configuration de notre
assemblée apparaî
indispensable je le redis aujourd'hui
devant l'ensemble des groupes de l'arc
républicain ma main et celle des députés
Renaissance est toujours tendu pour
construire des majorités de
projets nous le faisons déjà à travers
plusieurs textes transpartisans il nous
faut accentuer cet
élan mais pour conduire toutes ces
réformes un autre élément consubstantiel
au projet que nous portons depuis 2017
m'a paraît
essentiel car Monsieur le Premier
Ministre la France a besoin d'audace
d'audace pour tenir Leurent qui est le
sien dans le concert des nations et en
Europe d'audace pour préserver l'art de
vivre à la française et faire valoir ses
idéaux face au bouleversement du monde
d'audace pour se réinventer sans cesse
en accord avec son histoire et ses
valeurs et parce que votre action entend
s'inscrire dans la vision du président
de la République d'une France fière
d'elle-même je veux vous assurer ici du
soutien et de la confiance des députés
renaissance pour terminer mon propos
monsieur le Premier
ministre je veux vous lancer cet appel
le même que Danton fit jadis à la
tribune
de l'audace encore de l'audace toujours
de l'audace et la France est sauvée je
vous
remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président je vous
remercie la parole est à madame la
Présidente Le Pen pour le rassemblement
national
Monsieur le Premier Ministre mesdames
Messieurs chers collègues l'exercice
auquel nous venons d'assister tient du
rituel un rituel presque mécanique et
qui l' plus encore aujourd'hui un
catalogue une succession de promesses
diverses et variées sans lien entre
elles et de niveau pour le moins inégal
assez éloigné d'un discours de politique
générale mais ce n'est pas faire un jour
à Monsieur le Premier Ministre de
constater que son intervention n'est que
la revue de détail d'une déclaration de
politique générale que le Président de
la République avait fait avant lui et du
coup à sa place à l'occasion d'une
conférence de presse fleuve oh vous
comme nous et surtout comme le pays
subissons l'intempérance jupitérienne il
est vrai que le nouvel équilibre
institutionnel du quinena a trop souvent
ravalé et c'est malheureux le rôle du
Premier ministre à celui d'un simple
figurant un communiant un collaborateur
comme dirait un ancien président avec
Emmanuel Macron cette atrophie
institutionnelle est encore aggravée par
la conception autocentrée qu'il se fait
du pouvoir le président est ministre de
tout et évidemment le premier d'entre
eux pour aller directement au fait je
n'ai pas vu dans ce discours de
politique générale qui tombe lourdement
d'une des fenêtres du château les voix
et moyen du redressement je n'ai pas
senti le grand souffle qui puisse
emporter le pays vers des lendemains
heureux et pour tout dire je n'ai senti
aucun
souffle il ne suffit pas d'invoquer une
volonté de mettre fin au conservatisme
pour bousculer un système sclérosé par
des décennies de politiquement correct
de connivance de bétonnage de rendre de
situation pas toujours légitime force de
constater que non seulement vous n'y
êtes pas parvenu mais tout au contraire
vous poursuivez un modèle andogamique et
oligarchique dont votre Ministre madame
ouea Castera apparaît comme
l'incarnation
archétypal et puis il y a le fond la
valangeche de promesses à laquelle nous
venons d'assister ne nous laisse
entrevoir qu'une réponse à quelques
urgences médiatiques comme s'il
s'agissait de gagner du temps je ne vois
rien en effet qui contribue au
redressement des piliers effondrés vous
continuez à porter une vision
utilitariste construite autour de mesur
sans transcendance ni porté et surtout
une vision fondamentalement postptique
et post nationale dans ce catalogue de
mesur épar et parfois contradictoire
vous tentez d'allier un peu de droite et
un peu de gauche et en réalité vous
accommoder le pire de la droite et le
pire de la
gauche le pire de la
droite c'est par exemple la hausse des
franchises médicale où la nouvelle
réforme à venir du chômage le pire de la
gauche la hausse des taxes sur l'éle
cité ou la normalisation à outran je
pense bien sûr au DPE qui fait tant de
mal au secteur du logement et le bilan
financier de vos politique est apparu il
y a quelques jours un déficit budgétaire
de l'État proche du record de l'année
2020 la situation exige une remise à
plat d'une autre ampleur un grand
mouvement appuyé sur une volonté
nationale sur la force retrouvé de
l'État et sur une volonté populaire qui
légitime l'action publique en clair la
souveraineté l'état la
démocratie la première condition est de
rendre au Pays sa capacité de décider et
votre arrimage aveugle et inconditionnel
sur l'agenda bruxellois vous condamne
d'office aux mêmes Herm que vos
prédécesseurs à quoi riment les discours
sur le volontarisme lorsque vous savez
que vous avez laissé les commandes
intellectuel et institutionnel à
l'autorité supranationale de l'Union
européenne à qu bon les déclarations sur
l'agriculture au-dessus de tout lorsque
vous êtes prisonnier des logiques
décroissantiste du wisme vert appuyz sur
des ballots de paille vous parlez de
souveraineté française quand l'Élysée
use et abuse d'un oxyort d'une
incantation antinomique la souveraineté
européenne alors que la très
mercantileunion européenne a depuis
toujours révoqué le mot souveraineté
pour s'en remettre de manière
obsessionnelle à la seule loi du marché
pensez Monsieur le Premier Ministre
qu'au moment même où les agriculteurs
français manifestaient à Bruxelles
devant le Parlement européen à quelques
mètres de là dans un immeuble en vert
vos élus du groupe Renaissance votter un
nouvel accord de libre échange
désastreux avec le
Chili cela ne vous empêchez pas le
lendemain la main sur le cœur de
promettre aux agriculteurs français de
les
défendre les commentateurs amusés il
verront les artifices du en même temps
moi ces faux semblants m'inspirent la
plus grande peine pour nos agriculteurs
pour cette France rurale qui souffre
pour notre peuple que l'on trompe la
confiance pourtant si nécessaire en ces
temps de crise ne peut revenir dans
votre monde où l'on privilégie le court
terme l'éphémère l'apparence et où l'on
pense pouvoir éteindre les contestations
par des initiatives dilatoires le
mensonge la ruse ou à l'usure il ne sert
à rien de vouloir écoper le bateau qui
fait haut quand les membres de
l'équipage aux ordres du commandant
s'activent en même temps à ouvrir des
voies d'eau partout dans la
coque quel crédit peut-on accorder à ces
incohérences avez-vous comme premier
ministre seulement prise sur ce qui se
passe sur ce qui est décidé sur ce
système qui a fait le choix résolu de la
vassalisation à Bruxelles du pacte vert
au Pacte des migration vos choix
politiques ressemble de plus en plus à
des pactes faustiens on se perd en
conjecture sur les bénéfices que vous en
tirez à moins que comme faoste il s'agit
seulement de gagner un peu plus de temps
de
jouissance il est parfois compliqué de
comprendre ce qu'est le macronisme et
vraisemblablement beaucoup mê même les
observateurs avertis seraient incapable
d'en donner une définition précise une
chose est sûre il s'agit d'une pensée
liquide avec pour perspective une
société liquide parce que pour vous tout
doit se résumer à des flux la théorie du
ruissellement vous sert à servir les
nentilles le seul ruissellement qu'il y
a eu c'est celui de l'argent public qui
a coulé à flot avec votre cap vous avez
pour perspective de noyer la France dans
l'océan de la dette 900 milliards de
dettes supplémentaires en 7 ans autant
que le montant total de la dette
française en l'an
2000 cette liquidité que vous prenez
mène et c'est logique à la liquidation
Emmanuel Macron en tête vous mettez en
œuvre la grande déconstruction le grand
effacement de la France comme des
somnambules sans tenir compte des
réalités sociales ou de l'évolution du
monde
qui s'ajoute à l'abrasion naturelle du
temps quand rien dans la décision
politique ne conduit au
dépassement la première condition vous
disais-je c'était la souveraineté la
seconde condition c'est la restauration
de l'État et de ce point de vue je ne
vois pas dans votre déclaration de lueur
d'espoir la restauration de l'État
suppose de sortir de la grande confusion
politico-administrative qui règne dans
nos institutions nationales ou locales
il est urgent de remettre de l'ordre
dans l'organisation publique
avec le gouvernement des sachants dont
le saint-simonisme ambiant a fait une
religion en France et en Europe on
assiste à un va et vient entre fonction
administrative et politique entre
fonction publiqu et intérêt privés entre
fonctions électives et autes
magistrature il en résulte une confusion
profonde une confusion dommageable pour
la gestion publique mais aussi la
crédibilité des institutions leur
solidité leur
efficacité confusion politique lorsque
les politiques ont abdiqué leur
responsabilité et que le mot politique
devient synonyme
d'impuissance confusion institutionnelle
lorsque plus personne ne sait qui fait
quoi qui décide de quoi et même qui est
en état juridiquement de décider le
local le National le Parlement le
président le juge le Conseil
constitutionnel Bruxelles la presse
l'OTAN comble de paradoxe sous la 5e qui
lui en a qui lui en donne le pouvoir le
président ne préside pas pas il gouverne
et lorsque le président gouverne le
gouvernement se contente d'administrer
les affaires courantes que dire des
régions qui ouvrent des ambassades à
l'étranger des communes qui
subventionnent sans objets municipal le
trafic d'êtres humains par le biais des
associations complice des passeurs d'un
clan politique qui saccage la capitale
de tous les Français d'un préfet de
police qui est incapable de faire cesser
les vendeurs à la sauvette sous la Tour
Effel ou d'une préfecture qui entretient
des rapports troubles à avec des
individus impliqués dans l'acte
terroriste de treèb pour nous au
rassemblement national il n'y a de
restauration de la puissance publique
qu'à deux conditions la restauration de
la fonction publique la restauration des
moyens de l'État la question la grande
question qui est posée au pays n'est pas
seulement le programme de tel ou tel
gouvernement ce n'est pas la vision
seulement de tel ou tel président ce
n'est pas la bonne volonté supposé ou
réel de tel ou tel ministre c'est le
retour du politique C politique qu'il
appartient de décider et tout
particulièrement dans les ministères
dans les assemblées dans les régions ou
dans les commune l'élu doit arrêter de
se tourner vers le fonctionnaire pour se
faire souffler une décision et encore
moins une injonction les ministres
doivent cesser d'être les porte-paroles
serviles des directeurs d'administration
des féodalités bancaires de la grande
distribution ou des intérêts financiers
ils doivent redevenir les inspirateurs
des grandes impulsions publiques dont le
pays a besoin le retour du politique
c'est aussi congédier la pensée magique
celle du quoi qu'il en coûte ou celle d'
il suffit d'emprunter celle des experts
ou des grands prêtres de la pensée
unique la logique frileuse et
désastreuse du pas de vague quand il
s'agit d'affronter les problèmes à
l'heure où vous parlez de réarmement
peut-être pour vous donner des air
guerriers je ne crois pas avoir entendu
l'expression réarmement régalien ce
n'est pas un oubli parce que ce n'est
pas votre projet pourtant la question
est d'importance la France est-elle
condamnée à s'enfoncer dans le laxisme
judiciaire la politique peut peut-elle
encore continuer à demander à la police
de terrain les solutions sécuritaires et
sociales qui relève justement du
politique et de lui seul l'entreprise
peut-elle supplier les carences de
formation et parfois même d'éducation
c'est au politiques au pluriel de
reprendre conscience de leur rôle et
confiance dans leur voation qui est
celle de décider librement de la vie de
la cité des régulations nécessaires des
sanctions lorsqu'elle participe au juste
et nécessaire équilibre social mais
c'est vrai cela demande du courage pour
reprendre le cardinal de richeleu
fondateur de l'État la politique revient
à rendre possible ce qui est nécessaire
cela exige de la
persévérance le retour du
politique implique en réalité la
détermination à reprendre le contrôle à
le reprendre sur les forces
supranationales comme l'Union européenne
sur les féodalités qui gangrainent la
vie sociale et
économique sur les inerties
administratives ou d'habitude sur la
résignation de l'opinion lassé des
échecs de ces dirigeant et le moyen le
bras armé de cette reprise de contrôle
c'est l'état pour peu qu'il soit
respecté c'est-à-dire
restaurer la restauration de l'État
c'est la réhabilitation des grands corps
préfectoral ou corps diom
le retour du sens de l'État et au plus
près des gens partout sur le territoire
en métropole et en outreem la proximité
des services public c'est un état
conscient qui n'agit pas pour lui mais
au service de la nation un état
conscient que son premier devoir est la
sécurité intérieure et extérieure
l'égalité des citoyens et la liberté de
tous c'est un
état dont les agents sont honorés
respectés et récompensés comme le mérite
service qu'il consacre au pays c'est un
état doté des moyens de ses
missions la troisième condition du
redressement c'est la démocratie
c'est-à-dire le retour du peuple ou de
ses représentants quoi que vous puissiez
dire sur votre prétendu changement de
méthode Monsieur le Premier Ministre on
ne peut que constater votre incapacité à
sortir des logiques verticales à votre
décharge après c ans de pouvoir
d'Emmanuel Macron je ne crois pas que
vous puissiez modifier ce qui apparaît
être une marque de fabrique du
macronisme votre discours ce n'est
d'ailleurs comme un cruel réquisitoire
des 7 ans d'Emmanuel Macron vous n'avez
pas de majorité au lieu d'en chercher
une par le respect de vos alliés par
l'écoute par le dialogue et
éventuellement par le compromis vous
comptez sur des ruses institutionnelles
en excluant par principe les voies
transparentes et Scine de trouver
l'assise majoritaire dont vous avez
besoin l'élaboration de la loi par des
493 la mitrailleuse les décisions public
au marteau ou les atteintes au droit
d'amendement au nom de prétendu cavalier
ne sont pas admissibles dans une
démocratie si moderne lorsque le Conseil
constitutionnel participe au détricotage
arbitraire de l'expression de la
représentation parlementaire par une
lecture militante de la Constitution il
en ressort une impression de dénis
démocratique un piétinement du principe
même de la
démocratie B enfin qui peut croire que
le délit de séjour irrégulier n'aurait
rien à voir avec l'immigration et à ce
titre devrait être effacé de la loi un
pays ne peut pas sans conséquence
psychologique passer des lois sans vote
et parfois sans débat ignorer les
contestations sociales réprimer
l'expression des souffrances populaires
ou jouer avec une délectation cynique la
stratégie du pourrissement le respect de
la volonté du peuple fondement de la
démocratie nul ne devrait pouvoir s'en
affranchir vous devez cesser de
considérer l'exercice de la démocratie
comme une formalité administrative la
conduite de l'État comme un pass-ant les
institutions comme des instruments les
fonctions ministérielles comme un jeu de
chaise musicale ce que nous attendons
d'un gouvernement c'est qu'il définisse
clairement la grande voie autour de
laquelle doit s'articuler toute action
publique toute projection pour l'avenir
nous n'avons rien vu de tout cela ni
depuis 7 ans ni
aujourd'hui je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup la parole est à madame la
Présidente Panau pour le groupe la
France
[Applaudissements]
insoumise madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Premier Ministre Ministre
collègu vous nous avez maintenu dans
l'attente monsieur le prier ministre
plus de de semaines avant de vous
entendre délivrer un discours de
politique générale que vous devez à la
représentation nationale bien entendu
vous ne demandez pas la confiance à
l'Assemblée ce qui serait le minimum que
l'on pourrait attendre si notre
démocratie fonctionnait vous ne demandez
pas la confiance car vous ne l'avez pas
vous n'avez ni la confiance de
l'Assemblée ni celle des citoyens vous
nous avez maintenu dans l'attente mais
vous vous êtes rendu compte entre-temps
que personne ne vous attendait les
agriculteurs en colère ne vous ont pas
endu pour lancer un mouvement pour vivre
de leur travail leur avez-vous dit que
votre majorité avait rejeté une loi que
nous avions proposé en novembre dernier
pour encadrer les marges de l'industrie
agroalimentaire et surtout garantir des
prix rémunérateurs pour eux leur
avez-vous parlé de votre duplicité ou
vous êtes-vous contenté d'une mise en
scène poussive pathétique et
immédiatement échoué entre une botte de
faim et un verre de vin rouge sur une
autoroute beauoscoup de communication ne
font pas une politique vous venez
d'ailleurs encore une fois de le montrer
à avec votre discours de propagande
générale les professeurs ne vous ont pas
d'avantage attendu ils seront en grève
ce jeudi 1er février épuisé par
l'application de vos improvisations
ministérielles et atterré par la
nouvelle ministre qu'Emmanuel Macron et
vous-même leur avez choisi cette
nouvelle ministre est à elle seule un
symbole de l'ensemble de votre
gouvernement de vos politiques passées
et à venir elle donne votre adresse de
classe oligarchie SP par ici haut de
bourgeoisie vous y voilà fille du
directeur de publicist femme directeur
général de la Société générale puis de
saanof fille cousine d'une éditorialiste
de BFM TV niè d'une éditorialiste bien
connue du service public présidente de
la Fédération française de tennis pour
500000 € par an avant de devenir
ministre des Sports puis tout récemment
de l'éducation nationale des sports des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques la
pauvre nous disait-elle elle gagait
trois fois plus avant merci de nous
avoir offert une si belle caricature de
votre politique de l'oligarchie que vous
êtes représenté et défende quand on lui
parle de sa défense lamentable de ses
mensonges à répétition dans cette asère
du lycé Stanislas où des thèses
réactionnaires et hostiles à la
République sont répandu elle dit ne pas
avoir menti non tenez-vous bien c'est la
réalité qui lui donne tort en la matière
vous êtes des experts en matière de
politique économique et sociale
d'écologie de démocratie la réalité vous
donne toujours tort mais vous continuez
la réalité don encore tort vous
continuez vous mentez de nouveau vous
continuez Monsieur le Premier Ministre
madame oua Castera partage avec vous un
arrondissement du lycée Stanislas à
l'École alsacienne on se comprend bien
entre grand bourgeois madame ouia
castira n'est pas encore parti pour une
bonne raison vous êtes tous comme elle
alors pourquoi serait- à l'elle de s'en
aller la première elle pense ne devoir
rien à personne et sans doute doit-elle
vivre son ministère comme une peine
infinie car elle y gagne encore moins
qu'à la Fédération Française de Tennis
peut-être peut-être les effets cumulés
de votre suppression de l'impôt de
solidarité sur la fortune
compensent-t-il toutefois cette perte de
revenus
ouf Monsieur le Premier Ministre
l'étymologie de ministre est simple
permettez-moi de vous la rappeler ce nom
vient de ministère serviteur en latin
tout gouvernement doit être un
gouvernement de serviteur vous êtes un
gouvernement de serviteur sans aucun
doute mais vous ignorez quand démocratie
c'est le peuple que les ministres
doivent servir au lieu de cela vous vous
servez vous-même et les plus rich dont
les intérêts ne se sont jamais aussi
bien portés en 5e République que sous
Emmanuel Macron la fortune des 500
familles les plus riches de ce pays a
plus que doublé depuis 2017 vous en êtes
les serviteurs Alés mais vous oubliez la
République et ses principes vous
préférer jeter en pâure celles et ceux
qui arrivent sur notre territoire pour
ne pas parler des inégalités croissantes
du problème massif du lovement des
sansabriis des travailleurs si nombreux
dont la paix ne suffit plus de la
situation sociale insupportable que vos
politiques injustes font subir au pays
vous n'êtes monsieur le Premier ministre
à la hauteur ni de la situation social
ni de notre histoire démocratique et
encore moins de l'impérative nécessité à
transformer nos modes de production pour
répondre à l'immense défi écologique
vous n'êtes pas à la
hauteur une partie de la presse
sympathisante sans doute de votre
gouvernement minoritaire pont des
portraits ridicule de vous Monsieur le
Premier Ministre où l'on s'extasie du
fait que vous dormiez peu c'est
peut-être pour ce que le pays semble
conduit par une équipe de somnambule
ensommeillé dans leur rêve de
milliardaires ébloui par les lumières
télévisuelles vivant dans un spectacle
permanent que le pays regarde avec
consternation mais pendant que vous
vivez de l'esbrouff éternelle le pays
souffre vos tentatives d'hypnose ne
fonctionnent pas les agriculteurs à bout
comprennent que le libre échange la
défense par une poigné d'un modèle
intennable les marges les est sans
contrôle sont la source de leur
difficulté quotidiennes les enseignants
voient se créer vos groupes de
niveau idées aussi stigmatisantes
qu'ineefficace sur le plan pédagogique
comprennent le caractère systématique de
la destruction du service public qu'ils
honorent les chemineaux que vous avez
vilipandé dont vous avez dégradé la
condition social voit disparaître à
petit feu le service public ferroviaire
que vous avez détruit méthodiquement
pour libéraliser le rail conformément au
directive européenne les salariés du
privé souffrent toujours d'avantage du
partage violemment injuste de la valeur
produite les soignants et personnels du
secteur médico-social constatent en
dépit de leur engagement quotidien votre
obstination à mettre en pièce le service
public de la santé les chômeurs patiss à
chacune de vos réformes d'avantage de la
violence que vous leur infligez et de la
situation économique qui leur laisse le
choix entre la précarité ou la honte que
vos discours d'exclusion leur renvoi
toujours les jeunes pour le climat voit
votre incompréhension totale de
l'ampleur des changements nécessaires
pour faire face au dérèglements
climatiques et à l'extinction de masse
des espèces les retraités s'inquièent
des coups de canif que vous avez mis
dans le contrat social qui unit entre
elles les générations notre magnifique
système de retraite par répartition
monsieur le Premier ministre c'est le
peuple tout entier qui n'en peut plus de
vos politiques elles ont toutes la même
source le refus d'engager le partage des
richesses pour rémunérer le travail
engager les investissements nécessaires
pour les bifurcation écologique et
reconstruire nos services publics vous
déstabilisez profondément notre société
en vous en vous les éloignant loin bien
loin de la République sociale vous
resterez dans l'histoire comme le
pouvoir qui a ramené la France à un pays
qui a faim à un pays où les gens meurent
de la rue meurent du travail meurent sur
des brancards
d'hôpitaux une alternative existe
monsieur le Premier ministre et le fait
que vous ne demandiez pas la confiance
en est la preuve vous êtes minoritaire
vous le savez vous nous avez fait
attendre mais personne n'attend plus
rien de vous à vous et au citoyens qui
nous écoute à cette heure je l'affirme
une alternative existe oui il est
possible d'engager une toute autre
politique augmenter le SMIG à 1600 € net
convoquer une conférence générale
d'augmentation des salaires porter l'âge
de la retraite à 60 ans pour 40 annuités
investir massivement dans les services
publics dans l'isolation thermique des
logements les énergies renouvelables
dans un pôle public de l'énergie ou
encore dans la formation et
l'installation de nouveaux paysans comme
l'annulation de la dette des AG cultur
pour la conversion sociale et écologique
tout cela est possible alors je vous
entends déjà comment accomplir et
financer cela c'est simple en cessant de
servir ce que vous servez en taxant le
capital en rétablissement l'impôt de
solidarité sur la fortune en créant de
nouvelles tranches d'impôt sur le revenu
pour les plus riches de notre pays en
rendant progressive la contribution
sociale généralisée en un mot en
organisant le partage des richesses une
telle perspective peut vous sembler
abominable mais c'est pourtant la clé de
la cohésion du pays
aujourd'hui vous en êtes le facteur de
division abusant des pouvoirs que vous
donne l'actuelle Constitution la 5e
République vous rend d'ailleurs plus
invisible que vous le souhaiteriez sans
doute Monsieur le Premier Ministre
personne n'ignore que tout se décide à
l'Élysée jusqu'au discours que vous
venez de prononcer Monsieur le Premier
Ministre relu anoté et corrigé par le
monarque lui-même Emmanuel Macron est le
serviteur en chef et vous êtes à ses ord
comme d'ailleurs une bonne partie de la
minorité parlementaire qui a crubon de
voter il y a quelques semaines une loi
reprenant le principe de préférence
nationale défendu par Jean-Marie Le Pen
et ses héritiers siégeant sur ses bancs
un argument avancer alors vaut qu'on le
retienne certaines dispositions devaient
être votées car elles étaient
antionstitutionnelles et seraient donc
censuré par la suite nous vous nous nous
demandons parfois si vous vous rendez
compte du caractère planant de certains
de vos arguments ne croyez-vous pas
qu'un tel mépris pour nos règles commune
soit le signe d'un épuisement de nos
institutions la situation politique
actuelle dont vous êtes sous-produit
invite fortement à mettre sur la table
un changement institutionnel une autre
politique est possible une autre
République est possible pour renouer
avec la République sociale avec notre
belle devise Liberté Égalité Fraternité
il est temps de convoquer une
constituante et de rédiger la
Constitution de la 6e république la
République de l'intervention citoyenne
du référendum révocatoire qui s'il était
mis en place permettrait aux Français de
retourner aux urnes alors que vous le
refusez obstinément en dépit de l'état
de crise permanent dans lequel vous
plongez le P
la République de l'intérêt général enfin
une République où les ministres servent
le peuple et pas une oligarchie de plus
en plus déconnectée vivement un nouveau
gouvernement d'union populaire
organisant ce partage des richesses la
bifurcation écologique et le retour à la
démocratie dans notre pays à besoin nous
y sommes prêts avec détermination nous
préparons l'alternative à votre monde de
malheur Monsieur le Premier Ministre
emporte avec vous en guise
d'avertissement cette phrase du
philosophe Maurice merlenti qui disait
le pouvoir qu'on appelle lég et celui
qui réussit à éviter le mépris et la
haine depuis 2017 et jusqu'à aujourd'hui
vous n'avez réussi à éviter ni l'un ni
l'autre je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente la parole est à présent
monsieur le Président marlex pour le
groupe les
républicains
madame la Présidente Monsieur le Premier
ministre mes chers collègues au fond la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel
rayant d'un trait plume le travail du
Parlement sur la loi immigration et la
crise qu'exprime les agriculteurs nous
raconte la même histoire celle de ces
injonctions que le peuple français ne
supporte plus de subir de la part tantôt
de juges supranationaux tantôt de juges
nationaux
tantôt de technocrates bruxellois ou
parisiens mais ayant tous tous en commun
de ne jamais avoir de compte à rendre au
français si la souveraineté nationale
peut à ce point être évitée contourné
bafoué comment s'étonner alors que la
politique laisse à penser aux yeux des
Français qu'elle est devenue une farce
comment s'étonner qu'ils en viennent à
vouloir renverser la
table dans ce monde dans ce moment
critique de notre histoire dans cette
démocratie en crise qui est devenue la
France chacun d'entre nous se doit
d'agir avec plus de sens des
responsabilités que jamais sur
l'immigration les Français exigent un
sursaut vous leur livrez un tour de
pass-pe les Français en métropole ou en
Outremer n'en peuvent plus des discours
creux de vos catalogues La Redoute de
promesses jamais tenu vous osez nous
dire que depuis 2017 vous avez défendu
la souveraineté industrielle quelle
plaisanterie vous avez vendu Alstom
Alcatel Technip et et vous laissez
démenteler àos comment vous croire vous
nous parlez d'alléger le fardeau des
normes pour les agriculteurs mais il y a
à peine plus d'un an au salon de
l'agriculture votre prédécesseur avait
déjà promis la fin de la
surtransposition des normes
environnementales et dans son univers
parallèle votre administration est en
train d'élaborer des cartes de
protection des tourbières qui vont
concerner 30 % de nos surfaces agricoles
voilà comment vous trompez les
cultivateurs et ce n'est pas en
supprimant Monsieur le Premier Ministre
au 4at arrêtés préfectoraux que vous
allez changer quoi que ce soit vous nous
aviez promis des prix de rémunération
avec
égalim et en ce moment même l'actalis
propose aux producteurs de lait un prix
de 40 centimes quand leur coût de
revient est à 48 centimes voilà comment
vous Bernez les éleveurs il y a un an
nous avons voté à l'unanimité de cette
assemblée un calcul plus favorable pour
la retraite des agriculteurs depuis un
an vous faites tout pour que cette soi
ne soit pas appliqué il y a 8 mois nous
avons voté ici une résolution demandant
au gouvernement de s'opposer à la
ratification du Mercosur et il aur a
fallu attendre hier pour que le
Président de la République Pride de
panique dans un Paris assiégé demande
enfin à Madame V derleiden d'arrêter les
négociations dans ce même réveil brutal
on nous dit que le président Macron
serait désormais prêt à partir en
croisade contre les 4 % de jacher de la
PAC mais que ne l'a-t-il fait plutôt la
chaise vide du général de Gaulle se
faisait mieux entendre que la chaise
occupée du président
Macron la politique ce n'est pas que de
la communication un catalogue d'annonces
sans queue ni tête ce n'est pas du
théâtre c'est la vie des Français c'est
le sort de notre pays vous entendre dire
qu'on a décidé de mettre l'agriculture
au-dessus de tout fut un moment
formidable j'ai tellement eu envie d'y
croire et puis je me suis dit que cette
phrase me rappel quelque chose et je me
suis souvenu que la semaine d'avant
c'était l'hôpital qui était la priorité
absolue et celle d'encore avant c'était
l'école et la semaine prochaine ce sera
autre chose peut-être l'écologie la
culture et alors tant pis pour
l'agriculture sur la crise agricole
comme sur l'immigration les Français ne
se contenteront pas d'une Story sur
Instagram Monsieur le Premier Ministre
ou d'une vidéo TikTok autour d'une botte
de paille ils veulent des résultats dans
la vraie vie je vous le dis très
clairement monsieur le Premier ministre
tant que les réponses ne seront pas là
nous ne vous lâcherons pas la terrible
réalité c'est qu'après 7 ans d'agitation
fiévreuse à coup d'annonce choc de
grands plans de grands débats
d'entretien de sanie il ne s'est rien
passé vous êtes passé sur les mots du
pays comme des courants d'air après 7
ans de pouvoir absolu à vous écouter
vous semblez seulement seulement
découvrir le pays mais les crises
sociales se succèdent le pays est
exangle fracturé révolté ces crises
comme C C des gilets jaunes ont toutes
en commun que vous ne les voyez jamais
venir parce que vous n'êtes pas dans la
vraie vie des
Français votre politique
n'enthousiasme en réalité que ceux qui
n'attendent rien de la politique c'est
premiers de corder ch au président qui
depuis longtemps se sont émancipés et
pensent ne plus avoir grand-chose en
commun avec le reste du peuple français
mais la France qui a le plus besoin d'un
pouvoir qui la protège d'une concurrence
déloyale agriculteur ou ou patron de
petites industries la France qui a le
plus besoin de services public d'écooles
d'hôpitaux la France qui n'a plus de
médecins la France qui a besoin que l'on
remette de l'ordre qu'on enferme ses
dealers qui menacent ses enfants
celle-là vous ne la voyez pas vous ne
l'entendez pas et vous la laisser
s'enfoncer dans la colère comment s'en
étonner de la part d'un président pour
qui il y a deux catégories de français
ceux qui ont réussi et ceux qui ne sont
rien monsieur
leieur le ministre derrière la
communication la réalité c'est l'échec
de ces 7 années de pouvoir du Président
de la République les résultats sont là
monsieur le maire depuis 7 ans en
ramarqué de son empreinte ou plutôt de
ses emprunts son passage au ministère
des Finances creusant avec une assid
avec assiduité une dette àissale de 3088
milliards d'euros ce sont 900 milliards
d'euros de plus qu'à la fin du quinquena
de François Hollande en 2023 le déficit
est pire que prévu 173 milliards d'euros
et vous osez venir nous dire que vous
faites preuve d'une responsabilité
exemplaire en matière de finances
publiqu de qui vous moquez-vous et tout
ça pour quel résultat la croissance est
en berne 0,8 % 2023 et pas mieux pour
2024 le pouvoir d'achat des Français est
encore peu plus encore un peu plus
attaqué par l'inflation et les années
que vous aurez perdu par vos Herms sur
le nucléaire à faire du suivisme
derrière les écologistes vous place
désormais dans une situation situation
abrante où vous allez à la fois
augmenter la facture des ménages et
faire perdre à nos entreprises leur
dernier avantage de
compétitivité au ministère de
l'Intérieur monsieur Darmanin accueille
plus de 500000 étrangers par an c'est en
moyenne sous le SEPA Macron deux fois
plus que sous le quinquena de Nicolas
Sarkozi quant à l'insécurité nous en
sommes à 362000 coups et blessures en
2023 60 % de plus qu'en 2017
depuis 50 ans la France n'a jamais
enregistré autant d'homicide ou de
tentativ d'omicide magnifique record
pour votre gouvernement en matière
d'éducation vous savez la mer des
batailles la France s'effondre au
classement PISA 10e dans les années 2000
elle est aujourd'hui 23e en science et
en math 25e en lecture vous êtes au
pouvoir depuis 7 ans c'est votre bilan
vous avez également créé une crise du
logement sans précédent on ne construit
plus les Français on de plus en plus de
difficultés à accéder à la propriété
votre système ma prime renove réussit
l'exploit de rendre les travaux
d'isolation désormais inaccessibles à la
fois aux classes moyennes jugé trop
riches et au foyers les plus modestes
incapable évidemment de financer des
rénovations globases cette crise est
telle qu'on voit désormais en France en
2024 des salariés dormir dans leur
voiture alors quand vous nous parlez de
choc d'offre de simplification des
normes d'accélération des procédures
permettez-nous de penser que c'est un
peu court enfin le bilan des AD des
Macron c'est aussi un concernant
affaiblissement de la parole de la
France à l'internationale cette
singularité française que nous
chérissions tous ici a fait les frais
des attermoimements des paroles mal
drroite ou des gestes déplacés des coups
de commes sans lendemain du président de
la République renvoyer sans ménagement
d'Afrique décrédibilisé au Liban snobé
au Maroc inaudible sur la guerre en
Ukraine hésitant sur Israël la lucid
impose de reconnaître que quelque chose
s'est brisé de l'image de notre pays aux
yeux du monde Monsieur le Premier
Ministre vous nous auriez demandé notre
confiance après ces 7 années de pouvoir
nous n'aurions évidemment pas pu vous la
donner mais nous ne vous empêcheront pas
d'agir AJE besoin de rappeler que sans
notre soutien les rares réformes de
redressement de ce pays retraite chômage
RSA n'aurait pas vu le jour au contraire
au contraire nous vous pressons d'agir
sans délai pour les agriculteurs pour
reprendre le contrôle vraiment de notre
immigration pour faire vraiment
respecter la loi de la République
partout sur notre territoire nous
l'avons bien compris ce remaniement
ministériel vise davantage à infléchir
le cours des sondages que de l'histoire
ce n'est pourtant pas la communication
qui fera la réussite de ce gouvernement
c'est sa capacité à écouter et à
respecter les Français leurs attentes
français que nous représentons tous ici
dans cet hémicycle dans l'intérêt du
pays Monsieur le Premier Ministre tâchez
de faire mieux que ce qui vous a demandé
par le président et souvenez-vous que la
durée de vie de votre gouvernement ne
dépend pas que du président de la
République mais aussi de cette Assemblée
nationale où vous êtes minoritaire et
dont vous n'aurez pas la
confiance merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président la parole est à Monsieur
neigel pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outre mer et
territoire madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Premier Ministre mesdames Messieurs
les ministre chers collègues notre pays
est en crise les Français sont plus que
jamais en attente de réponses concrètees
à leurs préoccupations sans posture
politicienne mais avec des actes la
première de ces préoccupations la santé
on peut saluer certaines mesures
notamment le Ségure de la santé mais
honnêtement la transformation d'E
numérus closus en numerus apertus n'a
rien changé à l'offre de soins qui reste
totalement insuffisante dans un grand
nombre de nos territoires cela fait des
années que les députés de notre groupe
vous alertent sur la question l'hôpital
public est en crise la médecine de ville
est en crise en somme c'est tout notre
système de santé qui se délabre et
pourtant des solutions simples sont
envisageables la passerelle que vous
avez proposé pour les infirmières est
intéressante mais nous vous proposons
aussi de faciliter l'intégration en
étude de médecine et d'augmenter
drastiquement le nombre d'étudiants il
s'agit également de mieux valoriser les
personnels de santé cheville
indispensable à la qualité des soins et
de l'accompagnement dans la dignité de
nos aînés l'autre grand chantier
l'éducation nationale là aussi toutes
les inégalités doivent être traitées
notamment dans les territoires ruraux
qui voient leurs classes fermé tandis
qu'elles ont été dédoublées dans les REP
et REP plus ce dédoublement est une
bonne chose dans ces territoires urbains
mais il faut dans une logique
d'équivalence baisser les seuils amenant
à la fermeture de classe en zone rurale
le manque d'attractivité dans cette
profession est stigmatisé par une
nouvelle baisse en 2024 du nombre
d'inscrits au concours externes par
rapport à 2023 la perte de pouvoir
d'achat subi par les enseignant depuis
plus de 20 ans en est une des raisons
sur laquelle il faut continuer à avancer
de plus toujours sur la partie éducation
et pour une véritable inclusion scolaire
il faut Monsieur le Premier Ministre
drastiquement augmenter le nombre
d'aesh la place de la France dans le
monde est-elle aussi capitale notre
environnement proche est marqué par de
très fortes instabilités notre pays doit
continuer à faire entendre et respecter
sa voix singulière que cela soit
diplomatiquement culturellement ou
commercialement ainsi qu'à défendre
l'autonomie stratégique européenne un
beau défi international est devant nous
c'est celui de la bonne organisation des
Jeux Olympiques et par extension de leur
sécurisation la mobilisation
l'information la rémunération des forces
de l'ordre seront crucial cruciales pour
leur bonne organisation sur cette
question sécuritaire tous nos
territoires sont touchés nous l'avons vu
lors des émeutes de juin dernier
attention à ce que nos territoires les
plus en tension et notamment nreemè ne
soient pas dépossédés de leurs forces de
l'ordre on observe actuellement à maotte
un blocage total de lî qui doit nous
alerter et qui appelle à de nouveaux
renforts sur les questions économiques
beaucoup reste à faire un constat est
partagé par nos agriculteurs et nos
dirigeants d'entreprise celui du poids
des normes en 2017 il avait été annoncé
pour toute loi voter on en supprimera
deux Monsieur le Premier Ministre
remettez cela à l'ordre du jour
simplifier toutes les démarches pour nos
entreprises PME TPE comme pour nos
agriculteurs arrêtons la
surtransposition des normes le monde de
entreprise et des agriculteurs est
alerte aussi sur la transmission et la
reprise d'activité aujourd'hui plus de
50 % des agriculteurs ont plus de 50 ans
pour que nos notre agriculture vive il
est primordial que nos agriculteurs
vivent et transmettent leur exploitation
ils doivent pouvoir obtenir des prêts
spécifiques de carrière sur 25 ans et
des beauis à long terme qui permettra
d'avoir de la visibilité nous avons
besoin d'une loi d'orientation agricole
musclée et qui sorte rapidement avec des
objectifs clairs sur l'installation des
jeunes et leur rémunération est
absolument nécessaire enfin et c'est
primordial n'aortons pas l'agriture
l'agriculture que nous ne voulons pas
produire chez nous sortons les sujets
agricoles comme monnaie d'échange de
tous les accords commerciaux entre
l'Union européenne et les pays-tiers il
y aurait bien d'autres sujets à traiter
mais 5 minutes et bien entendu beaucoup
trop court Monsieur le Premier Ministre
énormément de problématiques son sont
sur la table elles demandent des
réponses concrètes et sans demi-mesure
nous serons exigeants et nous saurons
dire quand les propositions nous
paraîtront déconnectés et n'allant pas
dans le sens de l'intérêt de nos
territoires et des Français et des
Français qui les composent mais notre
groupe parlementaire comme à son
habitude se montrera pragmatique dans
l'évaluation des solutions proposées
dans un parlement sans majorité absolue
il continuera à être force de
propositions avec des solutions
concrètes sur les réformes à mener et
les carences constatées nous espérons
que nous serons entendus la situation
politique dans notre pays le commandant
je vous remercie monsieur
[Applaudissements]
néelen la parole est à Monsieur
duponteignan pour une durée de 5
minutes madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Premier Ministre chers
collègues vous entrez dans le livre des
records non pas parce que vous êtes le
plus jeune premier ministre mais parce
que vous êtes le nouveau Premier
ministre du président de tous les
tristes records record d'endettement
avec 788 milliards supplémentaires
depuis 2017 record de déficit commercial
record de déficit budgétaire avec en
2023 presque le montant de 2020 record
d'immigration avec deux fois plus de
séjours de premier titre de séjour
record d'insécurité avec plus 63 % de
coupt et blessures depuis 2017 et bien
sûr record d'impopularité car on ne peut
pas éternellement confondre présidence
d'unopularité car on ne peut pas
également confondre présidence de la
République et agence de
communication vous devez vivre monsieur
le Premier ministre dans le même monde
parallèle qu'Emmanuel Macron pour avoir
osé cet après-midi qualifier son bilan
de concret tangible et solide
je comprends mieux pourquoi Emmanuel
Macron vous a choisi j'attendais un
premier ministre j'ai découvert un
porte-parole un seul discours aura donc
suffi pour comprendre que votre
nomination ne changera rien et cela pour
deux raisons
principales la première c'est que le
président Emmanuel Macron et le vrai
Premier ministre comme sa conférence de
presse l'a démontré comment allez-vous
conforter les classes moyennes alors
qu'avant même ce discours de politique
générale Emmanuel Macron a annoncé
lui-même l'augmentation des franchises
sur les médicaments et Bruno lomer
l'augmentation du tarif de
l'électricité dans un autre domaine
celui de l'éducation nationale comment
allez-vous pouvoir répondre à toutes les
demandes de l'Élysée cours de théâtre
cours de sport instruction civique à des
élèves qui ont besoin avant tout
d'apprendre à lire en matière de
sécurité comment allez-vous faire
baisser la délinquence en conservant un
garde des saut et une politique
judiciaire profondément laxiste et en
étant fier de laisser détricoter une loi
sur l'immigration qui était déjà bien
insuffisante enfin dans le domaine du
logement vous ne manquez pas de culot
pour annoncer un choc de l'offre alors
que depuis 2017 vous avez
systématiquement sabotter tous les
mécanismes d'aide au
logement la seconde raison pour laquelle
vous êtes condamné à parler dans le vide
à agiter des éléments de langage
éternellement ressassé depuis 2017 et
que si le premier ministre est à
l'Élysée le vrai président est
malheureusement à Bruxelles c'est Madame
Van derleyen qui vous donne des ordres
matin midi et soir preuve en est mes
chers collègues la Commission européenne
vient d'annoncer à l'instant des
pêchesretaire que vous pouvez vous
procurer que les négociations avec le
mercosour continuit bien infligeant un
nouveau camouflé à l'Élysée qui
prétendait hier qu'elles étaient stoppé
de même au moment où vous tentiez
d'éteindre l'incendie agricole en tenant
un discours assis sur une botte de foin
un consultant en communication avait
vous dû vous suggérer que cela ferait
bien et les députés européens
renaissance après avoir déjà approuvé la
nouvelle Pâque et ses achè votai en
faveur de l'accord de libreéchange
avec le Chili après ceux avec la
Nouvelle-Zélande avec le Kenya avec le
Vietnam enfin enfin vous avez préféré ça
vous fait rire donner des gages au
gouvernement allemand plutôt que de
baisser le tarif de l'électricité en
sortant du marché européen comme on su
le faire l'Espagne et le Portugal alors
pour faire oublier vos doubles discours
successifs vous êtes condamné à
multiplier les effets d'annonce
vous nous avez livré cet après-midi un
concours un catalogue de mesurettes
avant-hier l'éducation était au-dessus
de tout hier c'était l'agriculture
aujourd'hui c'est le travail en
définitive vous me faites penser à ces
jongleurs d'assiettes qui dans les
cirques sont obligés d'en ajouter
toujours plus pour tenir en haleine le
spectateur jusqu'au jour où pataterra
elle se brise toutes ce moment est
proche car les Français ne se portent
plus les fausses promesses les
injonctions contradictoires le manque de
sérieux et de maturité dans la conduite
de l'État la disparition de la
souveraineté populaire sans majorité
dans cet hémicycle vous serez obligé
comme votre prédécesscesseur de
multiplier jusqu'à plus soif les 493 et
plus tôt une motion de censure nous
libérera de cette mauvaise pièce de
théâtre pour avec de nouvelles élections
législatives permettre au peuple
d'arbitrer et plus vite la souffrance
des Français la nôtre et la vôtre
Monsieur le Premier Ministre seront
abrégé je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur le
Premier
[Applaudissements]
Ministre merci madame la Présidente je
ne seraai pas très long
manifestement une partie des
interventions qui ont succédé à ma prise
de parole avait été écrite avant ma
prise de parole c'est le jeu on sait
comment ça fonctionne je voulais revenir
sur quelques points qui m'ont semblé
importants évidemment notamment
s'agissant de nos agriculteurs j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire tout à l'heure
dans les T prochains jours nous
annoncerons de nouvelles mesures en
soutien à nos agriculteurs nous avons
échangé vous le savez avec leurs
représentants pendant 3h3 hier il y a
des discussions continues qui se
poursuivent avec eux entre nos équipes
entre nous pour avancer et je sais que
c'est attendu et je sais que c'est
attendu depuis longtemps pour certaines
d'entre elles je veux revenir sur
certains points qui ont été évoqué dire
à Monsieur marlex que sur la question
des tourbières des zones humides j'ai
bien annoncé vendredi dernier que je
donnais consignes à l'ensemble des
préfets de mettre ce travail en pause le
temps de revoir les choses avec les
représentants des agriculteurs j'ai bien
mesuré le malaise qui existait autour de
cette question sur la question des
surtranspositions il y a un engagement
qui a été pris par le président en 2017
qui a été tenu pas d'interdiction sans
solution et nous avons assumé de
présenter un projet de loi et ça n'a pas
été simple je me souviens des débats
politiques qui sont intervenus dans cet
hémicycle nous avons assumé précisément
sur la betterave d'autoriser de
réautoriser les néonicotinoïdes parce
que la filière vave était en train de
couler les néonicotinoïdes pour la
betterave avaient été interdit par la
majorité sous François Hollande sans
sans qu'à l'époque la majorité se
préoccupe une seule seconde de savoir
s'il y avait des solutions de
substitution nous sommes élus en 2017 on
se rend compte qu'il y a pas de
substitution on a assumé de réautoriser
les néonictinoïdes pour la filière
betterave qui sinon serait se serait
écrouler et moi j'assume de dire
j'assume de dire que quand vous avez à
l'initiative d'une agence si
indépendante soit-elle une
décision de de d'interdiction d'une
molécule sans se préoccuper de savoir ce
qui se passe au niveau européen et ce
qui est décidé au niveau européen c'est
un problème j'assume de le dire et donc
nous devons regarder comment nous avons
une organisation qui fonctionne mieux de
ce point de vuelà sur égalim je suis de
très près et nous suivons de très près
avec mes ministres avec Bruno le ma
notamment on en parlait aussi hier avec
les organisations d'agriculteur les
discussions qui sont en cours notamment
sur le lait que vous avez évoqué moi je
veux simplement rappeler qu'avant les
lois égalim c'est la loi LME qui
s'appliquait qui donnait les pleins
pouvoirs à la grande distribution et je
nentends pas un seul agriculteur nous
dire que les lois à Galim n'ont pas
constitué un progrès qu'il faudrait
revenir en arrière ce qu'il nous disent
ce qu'il nous disent c'est qu'il faut
améliorer le fonctionnement des Galim il
faut améliorer fonctionnement des GAL
faire davantage de contrôle et prendre
des mesures on a parlé aussi hier avec
les organisations d'agriculteurs des
mesures pour la rendre plus efficace
notamment du point de vue évidemment de
la rémunération de nos agriculteur mais
nous sommes prêts vraiment prêts à le
faire sur les jachers ça fait des mois
que Marc fenau est mobilisé auprès de la
Commission européenne on a rallié 22
pays européens autour de nous et je le
dis je crois que nous allons obtenir
cette semaine je l'espère en tout cas
mais j'ai vu des signaux y compris
médiatique de la commission aujourd'hui
nous allons obtenir une nouvelle
dérogation sur
le sujet et à ce propos je veux dire au
rassemblement national et à Madame Le
Pen puisque vous avez vous-même mis en
avant le sujet des votes au Parlement
européen que quand vous dénoncez les
nouvelles règles sur les jachèr elles
sont issues des nouvelles règles de la
PAC que vos députés au Parlement
européen ont voté vos députés au
Parlement européen ont voté pour si si
c'est la réalité je je je vous votez
vous votez les règles de la PAC que vous
critiquez mais vous ne votez pas les
budget de la pack que vous demandez
c'est une incohérence absolue c'est à se
demander si vos députés savent ce qu'il
votent au niveau
européens c'est à se demander si
sincèrement vos députés savent ce qu'ils
votent parce que la réalité c'est que
vous nous parlez de protection vous nous
parlez d'indépendance vous nous parlez
de notre industrie nous avons porté au
niveau européen une taxe carbone aux
frontières ça faisait 20 ans que
notamment dans l'industrie en Europe on
se battait pour une taxe carbone aux
frontières vos députés l'ont pas voté
qu'on est de l'acier chinois qui arrive
au même prix que l'acier européen ça n'a
pas l'air de vous poser le moindre
problème nous avons assumé de porter ce
mécanisme européen à nos frontières vous
venez nous déclarer ici et dans les
médias qu'il faut renoncer aux
exportations aux échanges internationaux
à tout accord de libre échange vous irez
expliquer à nos éleveurs de porort en
Bret qui exportent notamment 30 % de
leur production et qui exporte en Chine
vous irez l'expliquer à nos viticulteurs
à ceux qui produisent du cognac à ceux
qui produisent des produits qui sont
massivement exportés vous irez
l'expliquer Madame Le Pen ça a l'air de
vous déranger que je vous mette en face
malheureusement de la réalité vous irez
expliquer à nos producteurs laitiers qui
exportte massivement là aussi pour 4
milliards en dehors de l'Union
Européenne notamment via le CTA que vous
appelez à dénoncer vous irez leur
expliquer nous nous sommes cohérents
quand un accord est bon pour nos
agriculteurs et qu'il est suffisamment
protecteur pour nos agriculteurs nous
assumons de le soutenir quand un accord
est mauvais et c'est le cas pour
Mercosur nous assons nous assumons de
nous y opposer et nous continuerons à le
faire c'est ça la
cohérence votre cohérence c'est que vous
êtes tellement contre tout que vous
refusez de voter
tellement contre tout qu'à la fin vous
en finissez par ne plus défendre les
intérêts de notre
pays quand on propose de
soutenir l'Ukraine de sanctionner les
oligarques russes qui ont participé à
l'agression de l'Ukraine là c'est pareil
ne faut pas sur votre soutien et ce de
vos députés européens je pourrais en
parler longuement je ne le ferai pas
parce que l'essentiel ici c'est de
réaffirmer et de dire l'engagement qui
est le nôtre qui est celui du président
de la République en ce moment même au
niveau européen et ça sera encore le cas
jeudi dans le cadre du Conseil européen
de faire progresser les choses au
service de notre agriculture évidemment
que c'est dur évidemment que c'est
difficile évidemment qu'il y a un
certain nombre de cas on narrive pas à
convaincre tout le monde emmener tout le
monde autour genou c'est ça la
difficulté la de facilité c'est la vre
c'est de dire on s'oppose à tout mais à
la fin ça fait progresser quoi ça fait
progresser quoi pour nos
agriculteurs ça leur permet quoi oui je
me tourne aussi vers vous c'est aussi la
solution qui est la vôtre pardon mais
vous avez là-dessus une forme de
cohérence aussi et vous vous rejoignez
dans la posture nous on continuera à se
battre pour nos agriculteurs nous aurons
l'occasion avec Marc d'annoncer des
choses très concrètes dans les heures et
dans les jours qui viennent nous serons
rendez-vous pour soutenir nos
agriculteurs et heureusement que nous
sommes là pour les accompagner merci
beaucoup monsieur le Premier ministre le
débat est clos je vous propose une
suspension de 5 minutes et nous
reprendrons sur le
vote